Hello!
Well, let's put some jazz.
hello the final heist the last stream are you guys i didn't
want to swap scenes i just wanted to stay there forever so
it'll be a never-ending starting stream if we never start
the stream we never end think about that i was like maybe
let's wait a bit longer just wait a bit longer oh guys
there's so many of you hannah thank you so much for the raid
thank you thank you hannah and also the raids oh my gosh
there's so many raids natsuki thank you and and oh that's
because i think you're easier for the raid but that was a
prime sub thank you azer for the twitch prime for 13 13
months and raru for the raid and and crunchy for also a sub
for eight months that's Tier 1.
Thank you.
Thank you, everyone.
Let's get some Bark Nights real quick for the three, and
let's get some last final claps and Bark Nights, guys.
Some last, and Sontier for the 23 Months and Tier 1.
Some last final Bark Nights, everyone, for all the new
subbers and the re-subbers.
This is the final heist, the final one, guys.
Thank you, everyone.
Thank you, thank you.
I really do appreciate it, guys.
Thank you so much.
oh gosh i am actually i've never i've never been like oh
shlush shlush thank you for the raid too i've never been so
stressed out for a stream because it's like i can't believe
i never thought i would i would like stop a stream you know
like stop streaming i never thought this would ever happen
it's just crazy i'm gonna wake up the next week uh while i'm
on the run at a motel 6 and with my bunnies and be like i
don't have i don't have to stream
Thank you everyone, Oswald!
Thank you for the 10 gifts and so's!
Thank you, thank you!
Can we get some more, can we get some more Bark Nights real
quick for Oswald, for giving 10 so's to the community?
Thank you so much, Oswald.
Thank you, thank you.
It really does mean so much, and Katsune for the 36 months
of Tier 1.
Thank you guys, I really do appreciate it, everyone.
Thank you for all subs the alerts are not on right now
because um i will be putting this bot oh i'm just gonna clap
all day thank you everyone thank you uh i don't have the
alerts sound on just because i'm gonna be putting this
stream up on to youtube as an archive for all of you so i
don't think it would be great to have like the screaming
Yoshi in the background for 20 minutes straight while i'm
trying to talk.
It'll be like, by the way, ah!
Thank you, two, one.
Thank you for the thousand vets in favor of the four months.
More claps, more claps.
I just can't stop clapping.
Thank you, thank you.
Oh, I'm just sorry.
One of my bunnies, like, dropped something.
And thank you for the giving us so too.
Oh, good.
Thank you.
More bark nights, guys.
More bark nights and all over the 10.
Everyone, this is the final the final time to cash in on
those bark nights thank you everyone thank you and Hannah
for the hundred bitties thank you everyone thank you Buffalo
for now to give this up to movie oh my bark nights guys
thank you everyone so my plan for today I don't want to like
drag it on drag on the stream really for really long because
I want to make it nice and sweet for all of you so we're not
gonna be playing like 20 different games and having like a
20 stream so the current set list for the stream is we're
gonna do the tour the final tour of the community minecraft
server um maybe a little small karaoke request song request
of songs i've sung before because i okay to be i really
wanted to prep uh prep for a karaoke set list for all of you
but i was my last final weeks were so packed with so many
things to prepare and everything learn new songs for you
guys i'm so sorry it was like i didn't expect us to hit so
many charity goals too so also juki thank you for the 30
bits thank you like i didn't expect to hit so many uh uh
charity goals so i had to like i stopped in my remaining
weeks to to like prep for those the streams for those so so
we're just gonna we could do a little uh set list of stuff i
could sing do some little karaoke requests of songs i've
sung before and guys just request and I'll look through it.
But oh my gosh, thank you, everyone.
Thank you.
Screaming Yoshi is kind of the classic, though.
Yeah, but I feel like it's going to be there for a while.
I feel like the Screaming Yoshi's will be there for a long
time.
Yeah, but she and Fly Champ, thank you for the 5 tier 1
community sub gifts and Fly Champ for the tier 1.
More class, more.
And more park nights, guys.
More park nights for everyone.
For the new park nights.
And Crunchy for the 50, thank you.
thank you everyone thank you so much thank you thank you i
really do i really will miss you guys i really will i
remember saw a comment what will you be doing uh if i'm not
streaming well i'll be on the run like i have to constantly
move around or i'm gonna get caught by i'm gonna get caught
by the authorities also also thank you for the 50 50 dollars
too thank you everyone Oh gosh, it did go by so fast this
month.
I honestly thought four weeks was not gonna, like, was gonna
take a while, but it felt so fast.
It felt like every stream was just like an eye blink away.
It's crazy.
I never expected it to go by this fast.
There's lots of tonight, lots of tonight for the final heist
is me, uh, yonking the subs in the month.
No, I didn't, I really didn't anticipate this at all.
thank you guys i really thank you everyone i can't even say
that with a straight face because i honestly i honestly
didn't expect this at all because i was like this is gonna
be the final stream you guys don't have to give me anything
any anymore guys you really don't people making you love
this stuff who's gonna pay for the motel sticks huh Go to
his buddies, aren't it?
Um, or the results of sending them.
Oh, I posted it on Twitter.
That was a, that was a Insta-Reject.
They're like, no, not Insta.
It took them, like, three days of, like, looking through my
application.
It was, like, is she serious?
And then I got the rejection.
Every other ones I submitted, it took, like, one to two
days.
This one took me, like, took me, like, three days.
So they were actually a bit confused.
They were, they were, they were, Also, thank you to
whoever's the namaskifter for giving us such out to you.
Thank you, thank you.
Go get some more park nights in chat for whoever the
namaskifter is.
Thank you, everyone.
Thank you.
Thank you, guys.
I really, thank you.
It really does.
Oh, my gosh.
Thank you, everyone.
It was three days.
Sorry, the script was too long.
They were concerned.
They're like, I have a sheet.
Thank you for the $50.
That's five more nights that my...
The Motel 6 I booked tomorrow.
That's why Mory Nights there.
And do go for the three months in a row.
Thank you.
I love you guys too.
I really do, guys.
I really...
Thank you, everyone.
Mory Bark Nights.
I hope this chat is spam with Bark Nights.
Thank you, everyone.
The final stream with all these Bark Nights and everyone.
Guys, thank you.
39 subs.
Holy shit.
everyone it really does mean so much thank you thank you
thank you i can't really say how like say that enough guys i
really can't you can't talk about motel on the keep it
secret
all right guys so first off we're gonna do a little
minecraft tour of the minecraft uh community tour so we
still be active on the discord i will not be i will be
leaving the discord.
I've decided that after much consideration i will be leaving
the server and we'll be handing it over to someone who will
be who will the discord now is all closed so no one can get
in anymore um but it will uh it will live on from you guys
my bark knights will live on in the server but I will be
leaving and handing the control over to um someone I trust
so you'll about it.
Yeah, no way in and no way out.
You ain't leaving.
You're not going anywhere.
How dare you want to leave the server?
The doors are all gone.
I deleted the door.
The server was my sim game all along.
I actually only decided to go get a DLC recently thanks to
Next, but I promised I'd be here for the final I said, oh,
thank you, time.
Thank you, thank you.
She went and took the ladder out of the pool.
You may not enter a league.
Welcome to Tomato Limbo.
Our rashes are ready really soon.
It's time to eat the other tomato children, guys.
Why do you think I grew all these tomatoes for?
All right, guys.
I'm going to set up for the server now.
For those of you who don't know the community server, It was
a, at first it was a single player server, and where I was
trying to build a hallway, and then for the final two weeks,
you guys all wanted me to open it up to everyone, so I
decided to, so we did a community server, and I'm going
touring around all your creations, and then I made you guys,
it was like free labor to finish my hallway too, so it was
like a win-win for everyone, you get to walk the hallway,
and free labor.
isn't that great?
I had a great time.
So yeah, the last two days I couldn't work on it anymore.
So I made, I made everyone else to work on it.
I mean, a few people have died on the sky hallway.
Because I made the hallway in the sky.
And then people fell off of it.
Because I didn't finish the sky hallway.
And I'm sorry.
Not really though.
I mean.
Alright, let me, I'll put the be right back screen real
quick so I can set up the, uh, set up the, the, the server
screen.
Alright, I'll be right back, guys!
I'll be right back!
Hello?
Alright, where did, where's Minecraft?
Where did you go, Minecraft?
Where, where did you go?
But I saw a question about what will happen to the YouTube
videos.
It will remain, oh, there we go.
it will remain forever on YouTube.
So don't worry about the graduation vibe, because I will
upload the graduation vibe onto YouTube.
And also, so those, oh, it's nighttime.
Oh, that's bad.
Alright, so this is actually not where we're supposed to go
first, but also, oh, my donation thing isn't updating.
Oh, thanks for letting me know.
I'll put that.
I just realized I forgot to open up stream labels.
Ha ha!
I was like, I won't be scuffed.
I triple, quadruple checked everything.
Whop!
Never mind.
And the person who did the Bury Back animation is Miflu.
Miflu did that for me.
Alright, so, let me show you.
This is where you spawn in.
So, uh, this was what I like to call the Pee-Pee-Pee kitten.
So, you climb up the the big Pee-Pee.
And...
you're like where are where am i where did i did this by the
way where do i go so um we climb we climb this this long
tower up here and then you're like oh that's where we go see
oh and this is like a giant tomato oh so shit the daily song
ah let's listen to a daily song multiple times while we
explore in true doki doki maple bird fashion we shall listen
to the daily song on repeat because i know a lot of you have
redeemed it wait what what is this allow ads on yes please
this is not this isn't the daily song wait why is it not
giving me the daily song Ah, scuff to the end.
Truly beautiful.
You know what?
There we go.
Betrayed.
Alright.
Yeah, I got the pack easy.
I got the pack.
I got so many people killed on the PP beacon.
So it's basically, you're like, where do I go?
And then, oh, that's my shovel.
Okay, and then you jump here and go.
That's where I go.
And then let me dig.
Whoa, that's a skeleton.
Let me head home first, guys.
So, it's a popular candy.
I should miss you out some stuff.
True, exactly.
Society.
I'm a girl of the ball, the star of the show.
Type a pony every...
Please.
Skeleton, please.
This is my final...
This is my final stream.
I'm a streamer.
Alright, so what's gonna happen?
The Minecraft server will survive for a month and then
whatever happens to it and then what happen happens to it is
Azir's decision Alright, so this is Azir's house, right?
So I Don't tell Azir because he can't watch the stream and
and listen and watch the stream and listen and play
Minecraft the same time But I killed one of his bees by
accident.
I took this plant out and I was like, oh, what's this?
And then I right clicked onto them and I right-click to do
it.
Don't tell Hazer.
He doesn't know.
No, he doesn't.
He doesn't.
He doesn't know.
Also, what's this?
This is up.
Missing Nevin Lee.
And this is someone's home.
I don't know who's home this is.
Oh my god.
I almost- I- I should not have this out.
I almost lit his home on fire.
Oh, Yamashu, I'm sorry.
I almost lit it on fire.
All right, so, um, what's this?
What's this?
Where is it?
Oh, it's Ito-san!
What does Ito-san do?
my house.
I'm so sorry, thank you so much for the 5,000 bits.
Thank you, thank you.
I really did appreciate it.
Thank you, someone.
Alright, so this is the tomato.
The tomato god, which is me.
That's me.
And then that's also me.
Look at me with my children before I eat them.
This is also me.
And this is my home.
Let me introduce you to my home.
So, this is a change were made because my my wait where do I
go oh changes were made and I wasn't aware of these changes
some some of these changes so people were getting tired of
opening every door from my Minecraft house so wait is this
the hallway oh this is not wait wait this is not my house
this is the hallway anyway that's the hallway
I realized that that might not be my house That might not be
my house I was like, that's way too many doors That's way
too many Too many doors to the hallway Anyway, that's the
end The hallway is the Wait, is this my house?
No Wait, is this my Anyway, this is my house This is, oh
let's Hallway is as may as well be your house Anyway, this
is my house.
Your slime's very fictional.
Oh no, they're my bark nights.
And look.
Oh, I didn't know this was here.
Look at that.
I sleep and watch myself while I sleep.
Truly, I am beautiful.
I like to watch myself while I sleep.
So I would be the last thing I see before I close my eyes.
And then there's my...
There's the little...
Park Nights, you guys are here with us too.
So, and then this is my mine shaft as well.
So there's like a pair of like chickens.
There's apparently chickens.
Someone's decided to breed some chickens in my mine shaft.
So, so I don't know where they are because the last time,
the cave chickens.
Yes, the cave chickens.
I don't know where they are right now, but they're in here
somewhere.
You're hearing them go there he goes or mine.
your cave chickens.
Yeah, there's like little cave chickens there.
So this is my mine shaft.
And I'm just slowly going towards... We're almost there.
Don't worry, we're almost there.
Don't worry, guys.
We're almost... Don't worry, guys.
We are here.
Look at that.
And then, this is also my mine shaft.
It's protection!
And then, you can go this way, or this way, which is a cave.
but we'll definitely won't be able to We'll definitely won't
be able to find a way out
No, it's extra protection every time okay if you ever watch
any zombie movie or any like movie where there's monsters
The reason why they die is that they don't close the door.
So this is extra protection.
You're welcome I these doors have saved me so many times
from monsters trying to get in there's no way in and no way
out just like the this great and anyway let's pony every
pony pony should also can one of them oh that's not supposed
to be okay one of the mods uh uh link the daily song oh so
how many doors many trees have died for this many many trees
have died for this i'll be the toast of the extra direction
for the morning
There we go.
And we're home!
Um, we're home.
Look at that.
So these didn't exist before.
So people would just like open and close it.
I would just open and close it myself every time.
And then everyone got fed up with that.
Especially with the hallway.
So they built, they built little, like, uh, those little,
like, thingies.
They built these little things.
Alright, whose house are we going next?
Who wants to leave?
me whose house oh there's b-man whose house that was my
house by the way guys and there's a little coy fish in here
too there's a little coy fish in here oh and my pool let me
show you my diving pool wait wait before before we do that
let me let me show you my diving board so this is my first
this is my first uh pp beacon because I this was not my
first house guys this was not my first house I had another
house and then I got lost and I died so i started making the
beacons to help me they were the first hallway i would like
to call this the vertical hallway also thank you ed for the
eight months at tier three thank you thank you thank you
thank you so much i'll do a little i'll do claps and then
there's my flower i put this here but let's give a little
let's let's get a little clap let's embark nights real quick
for ed for the eight months at tier three thank you so much
i really do appreciate it thank you thank you thank you it
really means a lot thank you so much and then all right see
this in anubus all right sparkies i love you twitch chat
more than a million dollars all right let's go in okay i i
mean up okay that was i actually didn't want to die there
and then where do i go who leads me who's leading me who's
gonna lead me so here lies frank coolest horse to ever die
twice wait there's a horse wasn't my horse okay that's doki
that's doki horse uh he jumped in there himself because he
has a little he really likes cows that's the doki horse I
couldn't find a dog so a horse was just the horse is like a
bigger dog that you can ride who's this this whose house is
this is this your house Rancid all right this is Rancid's
house I lied it's not that uh yes oh little bug what the
fuck okay I thought that was a little bunk beds for himself
the Rancid hole all right what's in here is this a mine
shaft all right i'm just gonna leave the mine shaft and
there's rancid's farm that's my tomato potato now so that
was rancid's house was there more rancid that was just scary
i wish i mean horses are just miniature dogs what happened
to the trees gone into the doors all right let's do i think
i have like two more plays of this all right who's whose
house am i going next guys who's leading oh did i did i hit
him i'm sorry who's who's leading me who's gonna lead me i
am a sheep i don't know where to go i never looked at i
never looked into y'all i don't know where where you guys
built your stuff am i supposed to know where to go you can
see the village of gulag the village of gulag all right and
there's me in the sky oh whose house is that let's go to
that house am I not running how do I run wait do I have auto
sprint off where's auto sprint where is it is there auto
sprint I don't know how to play this game please how do I
run am I running I'm running right am I running I don't even
know if I'm running everything feels so slow all right you
know what this is gamma he's mine too that's mine now whose
house is this I can't even take it up to I robbed I stole
too many things guys I stole too many
things oh and then there's a house over here so you have to
hold your spring key every time you want to sprint oh that's
dumb also bombtastic thank you for the eight months on tier
one let's do a little class can we get some bark nights real
quick for bombtastic for the eight months at tier one thank
you thank you I really do appreciate it thank you so much
thank you bombtastic the flying Sub truly it is I'm the type
of pony every pony every pony whose house is this oh Oh what
the fuck all right and thus I steal another I still one
thing from everyone I almost like ran over well I was gonna
say almost ran over ran over his cross but I don't really
know how to run apparently I don't know just collecting my
taxes just collecting my my taxes real quick oh is that the
dog house all right let's check the dog house ninja's dog
house oh it's dokey dodge oh my god i didn't expect to see
me at that oh
Okay, I have Vita's on.
Wait, wait, I can't see my HP.
Wait, I can't see my HP.
Wait, I ran past?
I didn't run past.
Oh, there's a random one.
Oh, that's...
Charlie, thank you for the stream once with Prime.
Thank you.
What is that?
Oh my gosh, is this a shrine?
Is this a shrine for my dog?
oh my god all hell dokey does oh look look dokey look dokey
doge I robbed some wheat for you I robbed some wheat for you
all hell dokey does offering chamber what is this let fire
consume all that is it Woo!
What the fuck?
I got burned.
Woo!
I ran into it!
Dog is love.
Dog is life.
Alright, so that was...
That was it.
What are these then?
Oh, is that just...
Time to work.
My taxes.
Gotta take your taxes.
Gotta collect your...
Oh, there's a naked sheet.
What a fascinating religion.
that was a doky-do shrine I did not it was not ready for
that I was not ready for that I ran out of I ran out of tea
guys someone someone give me more someone feed me all right
what's next who wants to lead me to the what get back here
is of more there's more all the teach at bedroom beautiful
it's truly truly oh it's the it's me looking sonic toes i
guess you don't know what this emote is we're watching sonic
the hedgehog and like the the guy rendered sonic toes very
very well and then i drew these this emote from my community
it is beautiful oh I can't sleep it's not daytime I know I
drew that while we were watching the movie together we had
like a movie night where we were watching Sonic the new
Sonic movie and that whoever animated Sonic's toes I want to
know how many how many hours they spent on it because it was
way too detailed.
It was way too, way too, way too.
It's like those lucky, what was it, iCarly, the iCarly show
where the creative iCarly really, really likes toes.
So people really like to take off their socks in that show.
I don't know if you guys really noticed that, but there's a
lot of shots of that there.
Isn't that a great final stream?
about so this is my hallway guys don't worry we will should
we go through the hallway are there any oh let's just go
through the hallway you know what we should wait wait no no
we should look at the mountain the mountain so I would like
to show you the mountain that sacrificed its life to to to
make the hallway so I did this I this was half of this is a
this used to be a full mountain guys i made it i made it the
mountain gave it half its life for us so also like i got
very i got very like stingy about it i actually like
flattened it myself i was like and i cooked i cooked
cobblestone uh to make stone so i could repair i can repair
the mountain
okay one of us didn't sleep so i cropped the i cropped the
protect the bear protect me you guys are fucking terrible at
protecting so yeah i did that i did that anyway let's play
some you know what let's play some oh that's a good song
okay all right let's do some um let's make sure let's put
some songs in there real quick while we look five minecraft
alright so let's start the mountain now we shall start the
hallway yeah I'll do the hallway last I'll do the hallway
last please stop why are they still beating me up why are
they so alright who wants to show me the next place who
wants to show me the next area someone show me the next area
alright Acer where's Acer that's not Acer wait where is Acer
where's the blue oh wait no where's the oh there he is there
he is alright we're going to the next area guys
I forgot that I'm just getting like nipped in the back I
forgot that the blue is diamond armor that's just the micro
sounds like why are there so many people in blue skins
it's really there's a lot of these places I'm seeing for the
first time because I never like toured this for the last I
think the last five, four days I haven't put went on
Minecraft for the last four days because it's so busy
prepping for all the guys it's a lot of things the hallway
is so beautiful, thank you the hallway lasts three days of
travel so get right oh my god
this is beautiful, no fuck Twitch
I refuse to look at Twitch.
I see as I stream on Twitch.
They rejected my partnership four times.
Is
this everyone who was on the server?
Oh, that's so cute.
Oh, that's weird.
Oh, there's a portal!
And then there's, like, the, like, the, like, they're just
beating easier up.
And then there's Mia.
Oh, thanks for everything.
Are those buttons for eyes?
Do I have buttons?
Can you press my eye?
Okay.
And then there's Tokey Doys.
There's Tokey Doys.
Oh, and then there's fish.
Jeez!
Oh, this is so cute, everyone!
The free daily song, the free daily song!
I'm the Montessor of the show, yeah!
I'm type of pony, every pony, every pony should be as
popular as popular can be.
Making my mark, making my mark in high society.
I'm the Montessor of the show, yeah!
I'm the type of pony, every pony, every pony should hang on
every word that I speak My approving glance would let me all
seek I'm the creme de la creme, just needs another Jane doll
Yeah!
I'm the type of pony, every pony, every pony should Home at
the altar on a fancy yacht Come the talk, the talk of all of
Canterlot I'm the creme de la creme, just needs another Jane
de la creme another jay doll that's the name of pony every
pony every pony should know oh oh oh yeah pony
pony i'm the type of pony pony pony as popular as popular
can be making my mark making my mark inside society i'm the
bell of the bombs and star of the show yeah all I'll be the
pony, every pony, every pony should know.
I'll be the talk of the time the girl on the go.
I'll be the pony, every pony, every pony should know.
I'll be the one to watch the girl in the go.
I'll be the toast of the- Toast!
I can't make this a talk!
I'll be the pony, every pony, every, every should know.
I'll be the one to watch the girl on the go.
I'm a type of pony, every pony, every pony should go In high
society, I'm as popular as popular can be Making my mark,
making my mark in high society On the bell of the ball, the
star of the show Yeah, I'm a type of pony, every pony, every
pony should Home at the altar, on the town, see y'all We're
going to talk, the talk of all of cat and treat lot and the
prem do the prem do just another chain doll yeah a type of
pony every pony every pony should know yeah
after a entire year of seeing this song i still don't know
how to sing it i still i still can't Sorry, talk and toast
is all the same to me.
Well, carrots after, all right, let's go.
Where's Azir?
Okay, Azir, let's go.
Lead me to the, lead me to the new, new area.
I can't believe it.
After entire year of singing that song nonstop, I still
don't know how to sing it.
I still, I still messed up.
It's always toast or talk.
Which could it be?
Every time I think it's toast, it's talk Every time I think
it's talk, it's toast Bell
Also, Jeremy, thank you so much for the raid Thank you,
thank you, I really do appreciate Also, look at this is our
map Oh, it shows up You can see the hallway, the great
hallway Wait, where's the hallway?
Oh, there it is, look Look, there it is And then it goes
underground here And then it goes here, and oh my god, it's
actually, it's so, so expansive.
This hallway, what was I thinking?
Why did I do this to everyone?
Oh yeah, okay, okay, not gonna lie, the hallway's supposed
to be a lot shorter, and I realized, oh, free labor!
So then I made the hallway longer for everyone.
I was like, at first it was gonna end here.
And then I was like, oh everyone's gonna be helping me out.
So then I made it all the way here
Isn't that beautiful?
It's like that's a turkey.
All right, Azer lead us to the next place to go I Couldn't
help it.
I was like, oh my gosh, I can make this hallway longer
Because other people will work for free Where do we go?
Alright, the village is through the hallway.
Alright, let's go, let's go in.
Let's travel, let's go in.
Oh my god, my chat.
It's so weak.
Alright, so this is the hallway.
It takes three to four days to travel through the entire
hallway.
Like, not like actual days, but like, um...
I just hear...
I like how you can just hear.
Oh, bomb, bomb, bomb, bomb, bomb, bomb.
Like, the click-click sign.
It takes longer.
The hallway ovens.
He can't attack me.
I'll put you in the hallway.
I'm going to put you in the hallway.
Don't piss me off.
It's never ending.
This is going to be really long stream.
We're almost there, guys.
We're almost.
We're almost there.
Trust me, we're almost there.
I saw Caesar slightly descend into insanity.
Look, chat, we're going down.
Clearly, we're getting closer.
We're getting closer, guys.
It's alright.
Ruby, it's alright.
Thank you for hanging out.
I've been dropping by, though.
I really do appreciate it.
Thank you.
Wish your mama happy birthday from this random stranger on
the internet.
She'll understand
How would you wait wait you're right oh, no, it's fine.
I look behind me and I see the trail of people You said that
and I accidentally turned too much I forgot what it was the
right way
No, no seeing person will ever be able to to get in exactly
can't break into my house You gotta go through the hallway
first It's okay guys.
We're almost there everyone.
We're almost there Guys, it's okay We're almost two days
later.
We're almost there guys Okay, just remember that before
before these trap doors before these like trap door thingies
We had to open and close them manually ourselves and then
people went crazy so now there's now there's these now
there's now there's pressure plates that's long enough i'm
gonna find one so before yeah so before then um people did
we're going crazy because they kept opening we have to open
and close the doors ourselves and people were like yeah uh
no they called pressure plates yeah i know i know now just
remember chat my first time I ever like actually played
Minecraft for for like by myself this is the first thing I
did I made a hallway and this would be the last thing I do
on Minecraft this is a many trees and rocks have died many
mountains and trees have died for this wait wait why is
there a hole in my hallway who put this hole in here who
robbed my house.
There should not be any holes in this area in this hallway.
Now this hallway is ruined.
Wait, am I going the right way?
I should be.
I am.
Yeah, oh, and then here, here.
Wait, why are there more why are there more holes?
So right here is, uh, right here is Am I going the right
way?
Right here is, wait, where am I?
Wait, where does this go?
Wait, oh, why is...
Wait, where are the...
Wait, where are the torches?
Guys, where are we?
How did you afford all this lumber?
You don't have to pay for labor.
okay why are there no torches in here guys where are we I
think we got lost right where where are we would I go
backwards wait is this this is the right way no this is the
right way we just have a hole it's no graduation out loud
why I hear no graduation I'm allowed I don't know which is
the right way which is the wrong way why are some so dark
it's like a spooky hallway now oh welcome to the degree
someone put some torches in here I don't know where to go
where does the hallway lead ask for us to find out later you
just need to let you know get out and then my haunted
hallway I What was that famous?
Wait, did this just lead to a dead end?
Wait Wait, are we at a dead end?
Oh wait a minute.
Why is there a dead end here?
Oh no, it's just we didn't open the door.
We didn't open the door.
Okay Hey Siri Alright, so, wait, what was I gonna say?
I forgot what I was gonna say.
So, wait, why is there...
Why are there so many holes here?
Poor construction.
How dare my free laborers poorly constructed my hallway?
I do not understand.
The holes are here taking the view.
No, that's not the point.
You're supposed to go crazy.
Not realize there's...
You're supposed to think there's no outside anymore.
after going through my hallway after going through my
hallway you're supposed to see that outside doesn't exist
anymore it's just doors i think everyone's like trying to
figure out how to get out right now oh shit okay this is a
sky hallway this is a sky oh that's the quote i remember uh
you didn't stop to think about how was it the scientist
quote the scientist tish quote but that's i am the scientist
and now we're at the sky hallway you might not know this but
we're in the sky this sky hallway has taken many many lives
chat uh many lives have been lost here for this building
because it wasn't a very smart idea to build a hallway in
the sky
i know the sky always view Isn't it beautiful?
It truly is.
You can almost see the clouds from up here.
Is this the one where we could even stop and think if we
should?
Hey, senior spicy peeing.
All right, don't worry.
We're almost there.
Oh, we're almost, based off that one horror game you played.
And then fire.
I feel so senior, definitely not claustrophobic.
great trap of course my many Yamashis were harmed in the
building are there murder holes that's for you to find out
when you go in the sky all the way now we're higher I don't
know if you realize that but we went up some stairs so now
we're even higher up in the sky this this is the spooky
still scare imagine this is better because you can actually
go crazy in here you walked into the great hallway of doky
land the long long hallway that takes more than three days
to travel there's no sense of rally from inside you just
lose track of time are we doing it how are you doing it's
been going great look there's a window now okay now That's
the other sky hallway.
That's the other sky hallway.
And there was our sky hallway.
Wait, where am I?
A big circle.
Also, Rocket, thank you for the four months with Prime.
Thank you, thank you.
Can we get some before we descend into more madness?
Can we get some more Park Nights real quick for Rocket for
the four months with Prime.
Thank you.
Thank you so much.
I really do appreciate it.
Thank you.
This can't be good for your sanity.
Ah, but you see here, I was never seen in the first place.
How long it says?
This is just torture.
Ah, yes.
The final heist where I torture my community.
My entire community has to go through this.
This is my final gift to you guys.
Who cares about the thing for the finals at the end of the
stream?
This is my final gift to all of you.
This always should be its own video game.
Nerd Turtle, thank you so much for the tier one for 10
months.
Thank you, thank you, thank you.
Can we have some more Dark Knights?
quick for nerd turtle thank you thank you thank you I really
do appreciate it thank you so much thank you guys thank you
all for all the final subs here the last sub isn't that
crazy this will be the last the last month where you get
class from me the last the last day for class we're outside
there is there's a door outside oh my god there's an oh yes
oh okay I have a door outside for the bee this was my
landmark this was my this is uh the bees dead though he's
dead i went to the mountain it's the mountain and well i
made i made it specifically for the bee but someone killed
the bee then it wasn't me and it wasn't me this time
also send your spicy pain thank you for the final month's
sum tier one for three Thank you.
Thank you.
Can we get some more Bark nights?
Can we get some more Bark nights In chat for seeing your
spicy Pain?
Thank you.
It really Does mean a lot, guys.
The final Day, final month To use the Bark nights.
Thank you Everyone.
Thank you.
Alright, he was a fool.
And then This is Sky Hallway number two.
Sky Hallway number Two.
Nirmal Dua.
I know French.
Nimrod, duh.
Alright.
Let's go up number two, sky hallway.
Why did I hear an explosion?
I just heard there are two sky hallways.
Why were there...
Was there a creeper explosion?
Why are there several creeper explosions?
Don't you just love the view from up here?
Don't let Doki escape.
Not only...
Not only was there one sky hallway, there were two.
So before we're ever doing a graduation stream.
That was the plan all along.
We never leave.
It's safe.
It's safe in here, guys.
Come in.
Do not worry about the monsters out.
Come in guys, come into the hallway.
All for the sake of safety, I'm here.
What did I miss?
It's been 20, 25 days and nights and we're still in the
hallway.
We're still...
Let's escape the police.
We have hallways, doors, and dead bees.
I'm scared now.
We're almost there guys.
We're almost there everyone.
What's wrong with the what's wrong with this
What's wrong with this?
I don't understand.
Okay, I thought these guys were gonna fuck me with me there
And then this is my village that I've kidnapped.
I have I've this is my village now This village belongs to
the hallway gang
Someone else reconnected.
This is my halt.
This is Doki the hallway monitor.
Am I supposed to go anywhere here?
Am I supposed to go inside here?
Wait.
What could my...
I would have thought this was great when I...
Wait, where are they?
Where are the villagers?
Oh, Roy, what did you do to the villagers, Roy?
What did he...
Oh, oh, no.
That's what he did to them.
I have made them use free labor to them.
They've gone insane.
They've all had villagers are in captivity.
oh and now that they're reproducing here too they're making
more villagers here they're employed the hallway broke them
all right this is all members of chat broken by the hallway
the hallway has taken another victim i see that so now that
we saw sky hallway let me show you let me show you ground
hallway under wait underground hallway now we're underground
you might not notice this but we're underground now
sorry thank you for giving us up the spoon egg thank you
thank you thank you so much Can we get some bark nights real
quick for...
Can we get some bark nights real quick for you, Zara?
For giving us up to Spoonay.
Thank you, thank you, thank you.
It really, it really means so much.
Thank you, guys.
Thank you so much, everyone.
Thank you, thank you.
All right, guys.
So, yeah, this is the underground hallway.
Isn't this beautiful?
Look, you can see some water.
What the fuck?
You can see a little bit of water.
Isn't this beautiful?
And people are dying above me.
See, look at that.
We're in the hallway and we don't get attacked.
Look at that, guys.
We're in the hallway and we're safe.
This is safe.
This is safe zone.
This is a safe place.
I'm convinced the outside doesn't exist.
And now, not only do we have two.
Two hallways in the sky.
We have three hallways in the sky.
We are on hallway sky number three.
A tree clip.
I realized there was really no point in making a hallway in
the sky.
Only because...
No, we can't even see the sky.
But hey, many died.
We're building this.
experience points for this build.
And Homicide, thank you so much for gifting a sub to the Sad
Machine.
Thank you, thank you.
Oh, Yabasi was slain by a zombie.
Thank you so much.
Can we get some more Bark Nights real quick for Homicide,
for gifting a sub to Sad Machine.
Thank you, thank you, thank you.
Thank you so much, everyone.
Thank you, guys.
Thank you.
All right.
Let's go to...
Oh, it's raining, but we don't know.
we're in a hallway we're almost there guys first not i'm
positive we're almost there now this is it this is the run
where am i is this is this the underground i serve oh am i
going crazy am i hearing voices that's
when i heard voices i was like what was that am i actually
going crazy now
oh we were almost there guys for sure we're definitely there
so you probably were oh thank you rocket that's really sweet
rocket so you don't graduate all right it's time for me to
okay let me get the sub to you guys i've never done this
before oh that's really sweet ruby i've never gifted a sub
uh to my own stream because No one has ever redeemed this
before, but I will, but I will do it.
All right.
Should we do, I'll do like a gift, gift a sub, gift one sub.
All right, here we go.
I'm doing it.
Who's going to get it?
Who's going to get the sub?
Congratulations, Vic.
Congratulations.
Can we get some bark knights real quick for myself?
For myself.
Please.
Bark nights for me.
Thank you, thank you.
Thank you, Mia, for gifting us up.
No problem.
Alright.
Where was I?
Is this the right area?
It's here, right?
Which way?
Which way do I go?
I lost.
I'm lost.
Which way, I'm lost.
Which way?
I think I'm lost.
All right, all right, another gifted sub.
Into the world it goes.
Another one bites the dust.
Oh, two.
All right, all right.
Who gets this one?
Envy, congratulations.
All right, another gifted subs, everyone.
Another one.
All right, can we get some bark knights real quick for me
again?
for for me again thank you and for Shire Rose thank you
thank you thank you to me and I guess Roy and Ruby for
redeeming those thank you everyone thank you thank you and
thank you me all right where do we go is it here is this the
right way Okay, this is the right way.
Alright, I lost track of all these gifted.
We've all of all the gifted subs.
Look, there's a fourth sky hallway?
I didn't even remember that there was a fourth one.
But now there's a fourth sky hallway.
There were so many, so many hallways.
I've forgotten how many there were in the end.
And then...
And then here we go We're almost there I swear guys, we're
almost There we're almost There now, for reals now Guys, for
real This is it This is it This is it This is it guys The
final frontier This is it This is it no i'm sure man we're
here and you're back where you started
this was my plan all along to make the whole so so whenever
someone spawns in you'll be like this is the right way to go
right and then they go through madness am i going through
this hallway any new players that that come in and they're
like oh there's two doors here do i go through here or do i
climb up and if they choose here then they just go insane
then they just go then they just go insane and all that
circles well in one hallway rancid's been lost we lost
someone in the hallway we've lost rancid can we get some
chat for rancid uh we so they can't go back rancid has been
lost in the hallway we don't know we we have lost him where
is he where did he go i don't even see his name anymore i
think not everyone makes it out i mean not everyone can make
it out in the make it out of the the hallway they're they're
just gone look down is ramsan out ramsan he's out he's he
did it he did it we spoke too soon he survived but at what
cost at what cost guys at what cost he's not the same ever
since he got lost in the hallway he hasn't been the same
again Oh my gosh, Ruby, please!
Was this all the, was this everything at the server?
Not blocking out the, I'm not being able to get escape.
Was this everything at the server easier?
Is there more?
Was there more?
I don't know if there's any more.
Because like I said, I don't really know what you guys made
here.
than um um the bits and pieces I saw while I was
constructing the hallway oh yeah I love how like everyone
else's like bills are so much nicer than mine like I just
have this I just have this
wait sloth was that your house in the middle of nowhere like
was that your house all the way like in the mountains next
to this this hallway next to hallway number four was that
your I found a random house in the mountains while I was I
don't know who the deranged man was it took 30 minutes oh it
took 30 minutes to walk you guys this was a this was a
fucking 30 minute hallway
Oh, that's crazy.
I can't believe Oh, that's yours.
Alright, let's go to this Let's go to the Let's go to else
Not else, I Dragon Dragon's house Yeah, so what you guys
don't know I'll show you a little secret in Dragon's house
So let me get there and I'll show you this Little secret if
not for the whole way Pretending us Alright, so you guys are
looking Can we go?
You can have your own little tour to the hallway if you want
oh shit i'm sorry sorry dragon sorry my now oh my now i'm
sorry it was an accident it was an accident i just wanted to
get up easier okay so let me show you a little secret um
with um with dragon's house and it's very interesting look
at this door hallway truly beautiful truly a sight to behold
all right so this little secret that i'm gonna show you guys
oh my gosh why are people talking in this song
all right well this is good uh a doorway oh so it's just
this all right let me show you a little secret uh from his
house so oh but what's this first what's this Oh, more stuff
I can steal.
Tax time.
Alright, so this little secret that I'll show you guys
really quick is that if you...
Uh, where is it?
I'm trying to remember where it is.
Where this little secret is?
Wait, what's this?
Oh, this was not the secret, but that was interesting.
Alright, I'm trying to find the secret.
There's a secret here.
I swear, guys, there's a secret here that I made on
accident.
Oh my god, Michael.
Alright.
Where is this secret?
Oh, it's here.
It's here.
Trust me.
We're gonna find it.
Wait, where is it?
No!
I don't know where I put it!
Oh, it's here!
It's here!
Secret!
This is my little, little hole, little hole behind his
house.
I accidentally mined into, accidentally mined into Dragon's
I didn't realize I was gathering more material for, I was
gathering more material for the hallway.
mine into dragon's house I was like what is this also I blew
up one of his chest too that's the other secret I blew up
one of his chest by accident when when a creeper showed up
next to me but it's okay I put everything back I put
everything back do not worry dragon everything everything
went was back I put it back So technically, we got, we got
to be able to ride in this house.
And so, you didn't lose anything, no?
You didn't lose anything.
Alright.
Oh, shit.
Alright, Michael.
Let me hydrate real quick and I'll do the Michael redeem.
Okay, okay.
Here's another secret.
He had cobblestone in one of his chests.
And I might have taken some for the...
I was like who lives here what a freak oh he has cobblestone
mine now that's the only thing I took though that was the
only thing I took that was I didn't want to mine more I was
tired of mining I was just like look at these cobblestones I
found on the ground look at that I don't
look at Look at these cobblestones I found on the ground.
Oh my gosh.
Okay, all right, let me do the mic already.
I'm the toast of the toast.
The host on the go.
I'm the type of toast.
Every toast should know.
I'm the toast.
Watch the toast in the flow.
I'm the type of toast.
Every pony, every pony should know.
I'll be the toast of the toast, the toast on the toast, the
toast on the toast, I'm lost, I'm lost, I'm lost, I am so
lost, I'm the type of toast, every toast, every toast should
know, and I'll be the one to watch the toast in the flow,
I'm the type of toast, every toast, every toast should know,
becoming as popular, as popular as toast can be, making my
toast, making my toast, Alright, oh my gosh, I actually went
insane there.
I think that fucked me up more than all the way.
Alright, let's end the tour!
Yeah, fuck you.
How are we ending the tour?
Ah!
Oh,
nope.
No, we're not ending with that.
How are we ending it?
I said, shift too fast the
egg is sad why are you sad egg why does it keep stopping oh
oh oh this is my house now look at that i'm safe because of
doors i don't need this all right is that it are we is that
how the tour everyone any final messages from my minecraft
tour my way through the hallway oh shit azer can you tp uh
ruby or that's ruby right tp tp
iglor the dokey squad whoo the stream will never end we're
gonna be stuck in minecraft forever we're gonna we will be
stuck y'all for forever all right guys that was a great a
group photo oh yes let's have a group photo where should we
have our group photo let's have it let's have it here so we
can see the hallway we can see part of the sky hallway let's
have it or next to me no no next to tomato let's go to the
tomato let's go to the tomato let's go to the tomato let's
all go to the mom today also there's this is the hot bar.
Let's all go to the tomato.
Someone's gonna die here.
We're gonna have the final group photo, and then we're gonna
do a little song request.
I feel like someone's gonna die here, and it's not gonna be
me.
Why don't we all have that tomato?
Let's fight the Ender dragon.
Alright.
After that, we're gonna do like a very very short karaoke
song quest of songs I've sung before because I am so sorry I
haven't able to prep like any new songs for you guys because
I was just so busy with prepping everything for all of you
And then here it is all right, so that means we gotta go
Here for the first
Why am I here?
Why?
He teleported everything!
No, he calls my town!
My town!
Oh, my beautiful town!
Oh, it's okay, the tomato is still alive.
oh my god it's okay the tomato's still there
it's okay all right okay other than the creeper right there
look at all this stuff not the group photo we wanted but
it's the group photo we deserve what is this okay oh my god
why did you defeat me here is there is any freak there's
creepers here
oh my god those are all scattered look at all of us
scattered we're like wait we're just fucking ready to the
hallway to the hallway if you want to live Do the hallway!
Do the hallway if you want to live everyone!
Wait, where's the hallway?
Wait, I'm lost.
There's so many.
Oh, it's okay.
This is what the hallway was for.
This is what it was for.
The hallway was built for this exact situation.
Anyway, let's take a photo of the...
Hey, Machikai!
Alright, let's take a hallway.
Let's take a photo.
Girl photo.
Let's take a hallway of the tomato here.
This is it.
We're all here now.
Don't stare at the Enderman, by the way.
Remember not to stare at the Enderman in front of us.
Oh my god, this is what happens.
See?
We were fine.
We were safe.
And then we left the hallway And then And then we left the
hallway Just don't look at the Enderman Just don't look at
the Enderman
Just don't look at the Enderman Just don't look at the
Enderman We'll be fine Are we good?
Just don't look at him Please I can't stop
I looked at his safety I
Did the one thing I was like please take me please please
what the fuck I Wanted it was one job Okay, all right.
Why am I in this home?
What happened to my bed?
Why am I in this stranger's home?
How did I get it?
here.
Okay.
Have we taken the photo?
Have we done it?
I mean, yeah.
Oh, I didn't even realize I slept in everyone's home.
All right.
Okay.
Crazy.
I was crazy once.
They locked me in a room.
A rubber room.
A rubber room with rats.
And rats make me crazy.
Crazy?
I was crazy once.
They locked me in a room.
A rubber room.
A rubber room with rats.
And rats That was crazy once they locked me in the room.
A rubber room.
A rubber room rats.
And the rats make me crazy.
Did we got the photo?
Did we, uh, Kimberley Rose Bollinger did our final stream.
Did we, did we get the photo?
Did we get the photo, guys?
Oh, we didn't?
Okay, okay.
All right, let's go.
Where's your tomato?
Let's get the, let's get the photo again.
Let's do it again.
All right.
whoever's doing a photo here come here so we can get the
tomato in the background your house dude i don't know
anymore this is it this is it me and my bear skin this is it
kill 20 the final photo the final minecraft photo someone
else do it i'm just standing here i'm just Someone else do I
don't have an f5 on this keyboard.
It's a 65% So not me.
I I not do the photos.
Someone else do it I don't have the necessary buttons for it
Who took the photo?
Or are we standing here forever?
Oh, it has to be me?
Why is someone else doing?
No Someone else do it someone else do the photo.
Oh Roy did it Roy did it Roy we did it Roy did it.
All right, I'm good.
Roy did the photo No,
I'm too it's too much Too much work.
Just press F five times.
Press F five times.
Alright, now I'm here.
Are we good?
Did we do it?
We're left.
So that means we did it, right?
We did it!
Woo!
That was our Minecraft server.
That was our Minecraft server, everyone.
That word didn't even capture me.
I wasn't...
I wasn't even in the phone.
it's okay how's she okay I wasn't even in my own photo I
wasn't I wasn't even in my own photo we do this again chat
how was it in my own photo how dare you roar
okay all right we're good all right everyone I'm leaving.
Look, I'm leaving.
I'm leaving.
Thank you, everyone, for coming to the Minecraft server tour
and touring my hallway.
It was truly an experience.
I hope you all enjoyed the little Minecraft tour of the
community server.
So, you guys do not know the server, for those who will
never be able to leave the Discord server, this Minecraft
server will be for uh for entire month so after that after
that it's azure's decision on what's gonna happen because he
he he's the one that's running it right now so thank you
everyone yeah get me i am poor now all the taxes i took from
you are gone now it's okay zino thank you for dropping by i
really do now you're all poor and i am rich all right
everyone i shall go now goodbye goodbye all right let me be
right back real quick guys as we go back to the general i
was no we go to the karaoke screen so i'll be right back
chat real quick i
am back everyone let's put some jazz back on let's put some
it's not over yet Just in time for this dokey bird over the
years.
Sadly, this was not done in Microsoft PowerPoint in 2010.
Yamashite, thank you for the five gifted subs.
Thank you.
Thank you, thank you, Yamashite.
Can we get some...
Also, Corey for the 100 bitties.
Thank you, guys.
Thank you.
Can we get some birth nights real quick, real quick, guys?
Real quick for Yamashite.
princess we did two months at tier one thank you guys thank
you I also hi Ina I saw you know just popped in thank you
thank you everyone thank you ah thank you everyone all right
so so this is a PowerPoint where I'm gonna give you a little
uh introspective also I like how tiny everyone is up there
uh look at how tiny yama she is let me fix that so Let me
give you a little... After this, we're gonna go through the
marshmallows, too, after this.
So, uh, we're so excited to get Bobbed!
Alright, so this is Doki Bird over the years.
I will... Zero, thank you for the tier 1 too!
Thank you, thank you!
More bark nights, more bark nights, everyone.
Thank you, Zero, for the tier 1.
Thank you, thank you, everyone!
Thank you, guys!
Thank you!
Ah!
Thank you, everyone!
little heart for you guys too we haven't had butt hearts in
a while because i i couldn't think all the follows there's
so many but here's all the followers too have a butt heart
everyone all right so let me take you my history so let me
take you my history before i start please bear with me
because um i was very young and and because i was very young
i didn't really have a sense of fashion you know little kids
when they think like oh this looks nice but it doesn't look
nice i thought it looked nice okay i thought it looked nice
on me all right so so let me show you in 2012 um i used to
have a twin i'm an only child now i'm so so i'm an only
child now What happened to the twin?
Well, we'll never know.
We'll never know.
The twin got eliminated.
Who knows?
There's no evidence or proof.
I've always been a thief since 2012.
I've always been a...
I can't see.
For some reason, I'm blind right now.
I can't see my chat for some reason.
I...
Alright, so, so I've always been a thief, but I wasn't, I
didn't have this outfit before.
So this was my original outfit in 2012, and I realized, hmm,
maybe beige and blue doesn't go very well.
So I went full blue a bit later, as you see my ex-twin over
there.
Can you see this?
It's so awesome.
But this was my very first outfit.
And my very first, like, how I like to see myself in 2012.
And I used to have braided, braided pigtails.
And so I was like, just twin tails.
I had braided pigtails instead.
And I realized, that's way too much work.
That's way, that's way too much work.
Do you know how much work braiding is?
So I, like that guy.
got rid of that so now we have our little our signature then
i got lazy then i then i got lazy
to enter one survive so i so that was 2012 survival the
fittest exactly so in 2014 i got my new alternate outfit so
this one you might recognize this one a lot more um uh the
twin still here but don't worry in the next line I became an
only child so but in 2014 uh the twin was my twin was still
there my twin my ex twin was still here don't worry don't
worry he'll be gone he'll be gone the next year never got he
went into the hallway and never came back I don't seem very
sad though but but that was my first alternate outfit so
handsome so that was my first alternate outfit and um this
is a very recognized you can see the signature I've always
kept the hat I've always kept my hat and my pigtails we
don't we don't talk about the at the pig tails we don't talk
about that time that was cursed that was when I didn't have
any sense of anything I don't know how to I don't know how
colors work apparently he's alive in my heart he's gone you
got accepted Link he got things he's gone forever oh you
mean VTuber I've always been me I've always been me since
2012 since 2012 it's always been me and then after that um i
discovered the world of v-tubing and then i lost my twin and
then i i discovered the world of v-tubing and i lost my twin
so that's a big gap i've kept it's because i kept my other
outfit uh my other outfit for so long but then I realized
this first model was done by etc who you might know from
Iron Bortex but this was before she was really in like she
she was in Iron Bortex but this is before the guild was
really popular it was before the big VTuber boom it was
really big before the big VTuber boom so I got a commission
for etc but she was I wasn't brought through Iron Bortex at
that time and and at that point i was like oh uh she gave me
the design of my first uh model back in she's getting milk
chat he'll be back yeah he'll be he'll be back but i'm an
only child though he'll be back i'm an only child
so um i realized i was like well um it doesn't look i
realized Even though that design, I really love my outfit
back then.
I realized that it might have been too plain, I guess.
I was like, oh, that's too plain.
Maybe I should, could you, like, spice it up a little?
Do whatever you want with the model.
Just spice it up.
Do whatever you want with my outfit.
Spice it up.
And then she added, like, all these new stripes, the
accessories, the pins and everything.
And I'm like, perfect!
Because I was like, I made that.
Thousands to have this done.
I might as well add more.
I want more accessories because it doesn't add more to the
value Your thing is it didn't add more to the value.
So I was like give me more I'm getting my money's worth
That's like this is not worth a thousand I'm getting my
money's worth
in 2020 in 2020 that was uh as your twin the tomato who
knows who knows i'm just an only child now what twin i never
had a twin guys what are you talking about i just been solo
the entire time what twin i don't see no twin here it's just
me where's the twin here all right never heard of them never
heard of them and then after that after that new 3D model so
this was the first my first live 2D model and after the same
year I also got my 3D model for it because I was like whoa I
can't have hand trackers but this one was done by Rika and
his guild Artemis cons and I got a 3D model because I wanted
to like use my hands I was like that this was back when like
i want hands how i'm gonna steal people's money if i can't
fucking stick it in someone's pocket and go yoink she just
turned a twin to a dog kappa and so um so this was the first
time uh uh this was my first 3d model uh so uh was that that
was done by like i said it was benarika and um we had lot of
things.
I feel like the only reason I used that model was to give
all the middle fingers and that was a good time and that was
a good time.
I think that was the first thing I did with the new model
guys.
I was like guys look what I can do.
Oh yeah and that's that was where the butt when the butt
hearts were born.
That was it.
Oh yeah you're right.
This was this was how the butt heart was born because I
couldn't make a real part.
Like my hands couldn't make a heart.
It just butt and that's where it came from yeah and i was
like there's a little hole on top of the heart like a little
butthole and that's where we um that's where it came from
okay the arrow but hearts and then i don't remember what
after this what's after this what is after this guys ah the
introduction of main first appearance of may may and bow bow
neko buster thank you for the tier one 47 months streak can
we get some bark nights real quick for neko 27 months oh my
god oh thank you neko It's so sweet.
It really is.
Thank you.
I have some fun with Blackheart Spring...
Blackheart...
Spark Nights!
Thank you, thank you.
I'm glad you had a great time with us.
A great journey with all of us.
Thank you.
It really does mean a lot.
Oh my gosh.
Oh gee, it was back when I used to play Overwatch too.
Back in my dark times in Overwatch.
Alright, so this was the very first appearance of Mei Mei
and Bao Bao and it was actually by coincidence because,
okay, okay, the lore is that, uh, the lore, the lore.
I found him in the laboratory and I took them.
But this was the very first appearance.
of Mei Mei and Bao Bao in July 2020.
And Mei Mei is the black rabbit.
And Bao Bao is the white one.
So you guys don't know which is which.
Because Mei Mei means like sister.
And Bao Bao is just bun.
Because he looks like a little bun.
I just stole them from a lab.
It's okay.
They're using up all my money.
They've been ordering Uber Eats every day.
So that's cool.
Why do you think I'm always broke, guys?
Why do you think I'm always running out of money, everyone?
So that was the very first appearance of my little bunny
minions.
The very first time they appeared in my life.
And then these were the references from my 1.0.
This I like to call this.
Well, not 1.0.
I'll call this 1.5.
Oh, this was the very first.
These were the very first official references.
of my 1.5 design.
Left side was done by Heartpuff and the right side was done
by WK4.
So they're both very talented artists.
And just a little bit of bonus for all of you.
One of the first reference sheets I have.
One of the very first reference sheets I have of me,
basically.
And then the next slide.
I think it's my alternate.
The alternate I just want to know this every a lot of
people's favorites this outfit was a lot of people's
favorites slime too so WK made me new clothes and I was like
I want 3d of this so I can move my hands with this too and
it was beautiful it should be beautiful simply simply my
beautiful so I can walk out in public you know because I
can't walk out like this all the time guys like can what the
heck like people would be like that looks like a thief hmm
why does she have traps everywhere that looks like a main
character of a show so i have to i had to get another outfit
done for myself so i could blend in i could i could blend
blend in with everyone in the public so this was my very
that looks like the
It has to tip them off.
That outfit, no, it's like, that can't be a thief.
She's wearing casual clothes.
She looks like a background character.
So that was the first.
Now, I think this next slide, I have a feeling what it is.
And I'm going to say, what I'm going to say is what could
have been.
What could have been?
So I've been, this one, I got this a while ago.
Like a long, a long...
Not a while ago, I was like, this, I don't remember when I
got this, but this was a little bit ago.
But before I got contacted by the bank team, I had a little,
I had a little thing I wanted to do, like, with my extra
cash.
So I was paying this off slowly by slowly, and it was, like,
with my extra cash I have that save up.
So, like, I would put a little bit, and I, my dream was to,
like, so let me show you what it is now, first.
Let me show you.
Oh, wait, no, this is 2.0.
Okay, all right, this is 2.0.
I was, I clearly forgot myself.
I forgot myself, guys.
Oh, I'm sorry.
I forgot about Clea.
It's hard when I'm already here.
Like, why am I over there?
Why am I over there, guys, when I'm here?
all right I'm sorry Clea I have too many identities guys I
can't remember all of them now there's four of me wait
there's so many of me don't worry I'll be an only child
again soon I'll be an only child again soon so this is I
feel like I talked about Clea the one I went with Clea I
talked about this before for the debut graduation stream so
I'll make I'll make this a bit more quick because a lot of
this was already talked about during the graduation
announcement stream, the re-debut slash graduation
announcement stream.
But I went to Klaya for 2.0.
2.0 because I was like, Radio K is the 20.
So at first, it was between the red and the blue color
scheme because the original design was inspired by the
Vocaloid song, Phantom Thieves, Phantom Thieves song from
Vocaloid.
and they're twins I'm an only child so so I decided to go
with the blue because the blue and the gray because I felt
like that matches well with the original colors or the
original colors and I felt like I feel like red wearing red
would make me much more noticeable in public like where did
she go look at this bright red color in the crowd is that
her so I was like maybe gray is better maybe it's like where
do she go it's okay the only person that's wearing red is
right there you can join and perform the reverse my toast
this so it was better for camouflage too the blending in uh
blending in with the crowd and everything and then we all
know about my cheeto bag over there where store my lock
picking stuff cheetos and my mic my mini mini trim like i
the tomato stains the merchant ah okay now i think the next
slide is the one i was going to talk about so what could
have been this is next one is what could have been guys what
could have been before the bank team uh caught me where the
bank team caught me so what could have been so my um before
my i had to i had that graduation announcement um my plan
was uh i love collecting i love collecting pictures of
myself because i'm a narcissistic uh because i'm i'm
narcissistic i love myself
I think we all know how much I love collecting artwork and
different clothes of myself.
So my plan before my graduation was that was I wanted to
collect outfits from different artists around different like
amazing artists around.
So I wanted to have like a little collection of outfits and
stuff from like instead of like alternate outfits, I just
have alternate outfits.
you guys know what i mean you guys you guys know what i mean
but alternate alternate universes but that was i would say
so this what this um it never got i never got rigged so i
only got to the point of getting uh the model or my outfit
so at that point i uh it was going to be done by Iron Vortex
and Art Gun, like between the two, but what could have been?
And we had Ito Song.
I was going to drink from Ito Song, where you're going to
have Ito Song.
Yeah, because all my faces and clothes were clip-ons, guys.
Don't you remember?
I could just easily clip on a different outfit and a
different face.
Easy like that.
Just take off, just take off my clothes.
Just take off my clip-ons.
and then clip another into the dociverse we go so this is
the docu-cinematic universe guys the docu-cinematic universe
so some of you guys might have been some of you guys might
have been confused about like oh where this I had this
outfit shown around and like different assets so like my
beer fact screen has that outfit on so you guys might have
been like oh where did that one come from but that was what
could have been what could have been and then there's ito
son and it was gonna be like flowers coming out like and a
question might be like huh but instead i get like
so and then we can have the little bunnies can like ride
along in incognito mode because People would think they're
just bags.
But no, no, no.
I don't know what they are, but at least the people would be
freaked out about them moving.
So yeah, that was what could have been, guys.
What could have been.
And we have a few more slides left.
We have a few more slides left.
So after that, after that.
Well, I'm going to talk about the different...
Let's just look back at the different merch I've got of
myself that I solely own because I'm a narcissist.
I'm a narcissist.
what can I say I love to hug a pillow of myself a little
tiny pillow of myself there's only one that exists there's
only one that exists out of all these I also have a paper
puppet this was done this paper puppet was done during my
1.0 outfit so it was a while ago the person I'm trying to
remember his name but but he it was before he like blew up
so it was very it was like he wasn't like super popular back
then because like it was 1.0 so it was around like 2018 2019
ish era so I was very fortunate to get one um from him yeah
it's like it is like ah there's a video of it I posted on
Twitter somewhere I don't remember but uh it's somewhere out
there it's somewhere out there um and now you got so yeah I
got so many around that time because I didn't know what to
do myself so much I just wanted so much and then after that
it's some of the little figures of myself some of the little
mini-me's of myself to look around so these are like a
little bit figures all of these they're like what other than
acrylic stand the acrylics on the right that I is given I
think ninja will have will get the because I only have two
in the world I have two of two copies of this and one is for
me and the extra one will be going to ninja for his donation
to the charity and then the food banks of Canada charity
that we had a while back and he was like the top donator so
he gets the other one the other other stand and then there's
the two little figures Ruby thank you for giving us some to
Slop Guy thank you can we get some can we get some bark
nights really quick for Slop Guy thank you thank you and
Ruby for gifting the sauce thank you so much thank you
everyone thank you thank you I really do appreciate thank
you guys it does mean a lot thank you but yeah they're
really cute I think the one in the middle is done by clay
clay pus the one that right it's done by let me look I
should have wrote down the names but I was in a rush I did
this PowerPoint today by the way but everyone's done by
thumb so all of them I've retweeted them um I retweeted the
artist to them on Twitter and alright so and the last one to
the left is done by Korean figure artist he he's like I I
don't know he's like been gone on the internet for a while
so so I think he got drafted into the Korean army so that's
why like he's been like enacted yeah he painted it on stream
too he painted it on stream and everything it was so fun to
watch i think i rated him i rated him while he was working
on the on the on the figure it was great he's he's what
you're doing also big deck thank you so much for giving us
up to lurker thank you thank you i really do appreciate it
thank you i can get some more park nights and chat also hey
next thank you thank you can get some more park nights in
chat for big deck for gifting us up to lurker thank you
thank you thank you guys i really do appreciate area i the
last two slides we have we have two more slides left guys
two more slides left so i did this let me talk about the
merch the the merch that we had the little our little shop
that we opened for three weeks i just want to say thank you
again for all of you guys for for putting pre-ordering um
the merch for these like i honestly did not to get as many
as I thought I did.
I, I, in my head, I thought that I was gonna get 20 at both,
at best.
I was gonna get 20 orders.
And that was me, like, aiming high.
That was me being, like, oh, I'll be lucky if I get 20.
And I actually thought that.
I actually thought that.
And, um, and then, um, I, I even, like, when I opened
pre-orders, I was like, if I if I just order 20 now uh maybe
maybe I can like uh as I open the pre-orders I was like oh
and if I order 20 now maybe I can get them before before uh
my final stream and so uh so I did that and then you guys
you guys 50 orders I got 50 orders in the end I actually
couldn't believe it and a lot while you ordered the the big
bundle too I was like oh my god so I kept like at first When
I hit, like, 30, I, like, DM the manufacturer, and I was
like, hey, about that, 20 orders.
Can you add, like, 10 more?
Like, like, 15 more?
And then we all must rob a bank of you.
So, yeah, I was like, I was like, oh, shit.
I was like, hey, can you put, like, 15 more?
Like, there's no way I'm going to get above 35.
There's no way.
And then we went to 50.
And I had to contact them again.
It was like, hey, about that.
that I have more I just have to order more I was like
there's no way to get about 35 and I'm like okay uh I need I
need like 15 more so I kept the the shipping for it kept
getting pushed back and um it kept getting pushed further
and further because I was supposed to get shipped like two
weeks ago and it's because I kept adding more inventory that
I got pushed back to like next like it's gonna get shit to
me next week but don't worry i gave them the actress to the
motel six that i'm gonna be living in so do not worry chat
do not worry and if i get internet service maybe i'll i'll
try and post a little sneak picture don't worry they won't
know where i am there's 200 motel sixes in the world uh well
i'll go to motel seven
oh my gosh well thank you so much for the three months of
tier one can we get some birth nights real quick for well
thank you thank you thank you really do appreciate it thank
you so much thank you guys thank you thank you thank you i
really do appreciate guys thank you so much for the support
for this final stream it's hot we're almost getting closer
to the end guys there's like two more things left on my
little list of things i want to do for my final stream and
we're getting there getting there oh my gosh yeah Thank you,
everyone.
Oh my gosh, Ward.
Let me hydrate for that.
Ward, let me...
Okay.
According to all knowns of aviation, there is no way a bee
should be able to fly.
Its wings are too small to get his fat little body off the
ground.
The bee, of course, flies anyway because bees don't care
what human think is impossible.
Yellow, black, yellow, black, yellow, black, yellow, black.
Oh, black and yellow.
Let's shake you up a little.
Barry, breakfast is ready.
Cool, babe.
Hang on a second.
Hello, Barry.
Adam, can you believe this is happening?
I can't.
I'll pick you up.
Looking, shock.
Arp.
Use the stairs.
Your father paid good money for those.
Sorry, I'm excited.
Here's the graduate.
We're very proud of you, son.
A perfect report card.
All of these.
Very proud.
I got a thing going here.
You got lint in your fuzz.
Oh, that's me.
Wait to us.
We'll be in row 118,000.
Bye.
Barry, I told you.
Stop flying in the house.
Hey, Adam.
Hey, Barry.
Oh, fuck you guys.
Is that, is that fun still?
A little special day graduation.
Never thought I'd make it.
The three days, great school.
Three days, high school.
Those were Lige, I'm glad I took a day and hitchhiked around
the hive.
You did come back different.
Hi, Barry.
Already?
Growing a mustache?
Looks good.
Hear about Frankie?
Yeah.
You going to a funeral?
No, I'm not going.
Everybody knows.
Sting someone, you die.
Don't waste it on a squirrel.
Such a hothead.
I guess he could have gone out the way.
I love this.
Incorporating amusement park into your day.
That's why we don't need vaccinations.
Boy, quite a bit of pomp under your circumstances.
Well, Ada, mmm, today we are men.
We are B-men, A-men, hallelujah.
Students, faculty, distinguished Bs.
Please welcome Dean Boswell.
Welcome, New High City graduating class of 9-15.
That concludes our ceremony and begins your career at Honex
Industry.
Well, we pick our job today.
My heart is just orientation.
Here we go!
Keep your hands on talent and sign a talent on times!
Wonder what it'll be like!
A little scary!
Welcome to Hannex, a divisional homescone and a part of the
hexagon grow!
Up!
This is it!
I've worked your whole life to get to the point where you
can work your whole life!
Honey begins when our valley and pollen jogs bring the net
critter to the hive.
Our top secret formula is automatically color corrected, set
adjusted, and bubble contoured into the soothing sweet syrup
of its distinctive golden glow you know as honey that girl
was hot she's my cousin she is yeah we're all cousins right
you're right as honics we constantly strive to improve every
aspect of eating food since the bees are stress testing a
new helmet technology what do you think he makes not enough
here we have our latest advanced the Kremlin.
What does that do?
Catches that little shaman of money that hangs after you
pour it.
Save us millions.
Can anyone work on the Kremlin?
Of course!
Most bee jobs are small ones, but bees know what every small
job, if it's not well, means a lot.
But choose carefully, because you'll stay in the job,
constantly trying to improve every aspect of bee existence.
These Dress testing, a new helmet technology.
What do you think he makes?
Not enough.
He only, if I'm our latest investment, the Kremlin.
What does that do?
Catches the last strand of honey that hangs after you pour
it.
Saves us millions.
Can anyone work on the Kremlin?
Of course.
Most bee jobs are small ones.
But bees know that every small job, if it's done well, means
a lot.
But choose carefully because...
Okay, I'm closing the...
I'm closing her day.
I thought you guys, you guys went too far.
You guys went too far.
I just kept going.
I'm losing him.
Too much.
It's too much.
I was like, no more.
No more.
Now no one has channel points.
Now no one has channel points anymore.
Think about your actions now.
I have in the end, this was the heist all along.
This was the heist on the long guys.
this was the this was the true heist all along guys we the
true and finalized to end all heist the end all heist all
right because because of this i will read all the other ones
that we had left i will i will read the rest of it
Oh my god.
Like, I don't even know where I was.
Alright.
She's my cousin.
She is?
We're all cousins.
Right, you're right.
At Honix, we call Maple Bow.
We constantly strive to improve every aspect of bee
existence.
These bees.
Oh, wait.
Am I reading this again?
Oh, she's not.
Let me skip the...
Wait.
Okay.
What do you think you make?
Not enough.
Well, here we have our latest, our latest advancement.
The Kremlin, what does he do?
Catches a little strand of honey that hangs after you pour
it?
Saves us millions.
Can anyone work on the Kremlin?
Of course.
Most bee jobs are small ones, but bees know that every small
job, if it's done well, means a lot.
But choose carefully, because you'll stay in the job today.
I heard it's just orientation.
Heads up, here we go.
Keep your hands and antennas.
inside the tram at all times when it will be like a little
scary welcome to honex a division of homes code and a part
of the hexagon group this is it wow wow we know that you as
a bee have worked your whole life to get to the point where
you can work for your whole life honey begins when our
valiant pollen dogs bring the nectar to the hive our top
secret formula is automatically colored correct today we are
men we are men be men amen hallelujah Students, facilities,
faculty, distinguished beings.
Please welcome Dean Boswell.
Welcome new high graduate in class of 1950.
That concludes our ceremonies and begins your career in
Honex Industries.
Will we pick our job today?
I heard it's just orientation.
Heads up.
Here we go.
Keep your hands and antennas inside the tram at all times.
Wonder what it would be like.
A little scary.
Welcome, Honex.
You should have home kind of part of the hexagon grow.
scent adjusted and bubble contoured into the soothing sweet
syrup with a distinctly golden glow known as honey that girl
was hot she's my cousin she is yes or all cousins right
you're right at honics we constantly strive to improve every
aspect of be existent babies are stress testing a new helmet
technology what do you think he makes not enough here we
have our latest events with the Kremlin what does that do
catches a little stride of honey after you pour it sees this
million.
Can anyone work on the Kremlin?
Of course.
Must be.
Just know that every.
She's my cousins.
Your cousin.
We're all cousins.
I'm going in circles.
Oh yeah.
I'm like getting rereading the same part.
But I'm falling.
Because people keep following.
So I kept reading the same thing over and over again.
Because I kept
Wait, we're done here.
We're gonna remain done here.
Your own presence.
Oh my god.
I've been broken.
This is paid back for the hallway, isn't it?
Now we, this is paid back for the hallway.
What do you mean?
I have to keep, I already finished it.
I just kept reading the same thing over.
and over again.
I already finished this like 20 million.
Wait, you're worried?
Alright, chat.
Where are you?
Fly chat.
There's so many.
I don't know which one's you.
Where is it?
Wait, where is it?
I saw it.
What did you redeem?
No!
Alright, there we go.
Also, Geek Girl, thank you for gifting a three month tier 1
song to go.
And Luke, thank you for solving for nine months at tier 1.
And Geek Girl, thank you for two months at tier 1.
Thank you, thank you.
I'm gonna get some bark nights or a little quick for all the
subs.
Thank you, thank you, thank you.
thank you everyone thank you so much i really do appreciate
it thank you guys thank you all so much thank you everyone
it really does mean a lot thank you thank you thank you
thank you all
you guys deserve you guys deserve that for uh for making me
do the loop for making me do the It says they're open like,
oh, I seem exhausted from it.
You could have stopped and we all could have had our point,
but no, we're all cousins.
All right.
Okay, excuse me.
Now we're all cousins.
We want, yeah, you guys want to know 100% the time.
on the entire script.
That was the final heist.
That was it.
Oswald, thank you for the sale.
Fuck you.
Jokes on you.
Chats hiding your donation.
So I can't see the...
I can't see what you wrote there.
You mad lad.
Ah, the way of the thief.
No, honestly.
But I knew what...
I saw.
The aviation laws and I knew I saw the aviation laws Poking
at the top I can't believe in ice it like that
Oh my gosh also there's still one more slide The final heist
is about to end But not yet It's almost close we have two
more things We have two more things so one of the things I
was gonna do One of the things I was gonna do is the Um It's
the...
The...
Marshmallows!
It's the marshmallows, guys.
You thought I forgot about the marshmallows?
So...
Oh my god!
That's a lot of marshmallows.
I didn't think I would get this many.
I honestly did it.
Let's read them.
I will not cry.
I promise.
I won't cry, guys.
I won't.
I won't, guys.
oh let me hydrate real quick before i before i cry all of it
to cry all of it out let me cry all of it out okay now i cry
i'm gonna try not to cry guys we're gonna we're gonna try
not to cry guys all right marshmallow okay so so here's the
marshmallow let's read this together they chat.
Let's read these and I have to refresh it.
Alright guys.
I'm trying not to cry.
Alright.
Ah guys.
It's 24.
I didn't expect that many.
I didn't know what to say here but it's only been a few
weeks since I found you.
I'm not good with words and I'm really shy so for me it's so
difficult to talk with people but I really enjoyed every
stream this last week.
You really many times.
All my problems disappear when you hear your love.
I'm really sad that you're graduating.
I'll miss watching you.
I'll miss the bark nights and I'll miss staying late and
sleeping only one hour.
You're welcome.
Thank you, Doki.
Thank you.
Why did rotten tomato always felt left up Because he
couldn't catch up.
Yeah, I know.
Finishing with Tamio-Pun is not the best.
But I really wanted to say it.
Aww.
It's okay.
My VODs are still.
Well, my VODs on YouTube are still up.
Just listen to the...
If you record it and put it in like...
If you have a Doki Makura.
Record my laugh.
Put it in the Doki Makura.
And then it's like I'm always there laughing at you.
With you.
with you.
That's what's...
Alright, let's go to the next...
Please, someone do it!
You always laugh at me!
Aww, Phantom!
That was really, really sweet.
That was really sweet.
Marshmallow.
I'm not...
I just met you, but it feels like I missed...
It's okay as long as like you were there now before I was
gone.
You were there when I was alive.
When I was alive.
Remind me I'm always alive.
I'm not great with words or at least emotional ones.
Your streams have helped me keep me staying through the ups
and mostly downs of my life for the past two years.
Thanks for being the coolest burp.
No, thank you guys.
It really, you know, you guys also cheer me up so much too.
Whenever I have, like, a bad day, and then I would be like,
should I really stream?
No, I feel like shit right now.
I just feel so much better hanging out with you guys just
talking I think this is why um This is why I I always do a
lot of chatting streams too Definitely do a lot of like
chatting streams and a lot of just like chilling like you
guys like know See how my art stream is mostly me talking
because I love talking to you guys I love talking with the
community and just like hanging out and have you enabled my
dumb ass Dumb dumb ass chaotic lives like
You guys enabling me And it makes me happy.
It makes me happy.
But thank you guys.
You guys do as much as I do for you guys.
You guys make me happy.
And I'm happy that I make you guys happy.
Doki Chan.
I want to say thank you so much for bringing me smiles,
laughter, and lots of warmth for so long.
You really do brighten up my day.
It made me believe that I could be the best that I can be.
I don't know if my words will reach you in time.
but just know that not a day goes by well me thinking of you
and i give you all my wonderful wishes you stole my heart
the day i crossed past with you and although i'm quiet in
the lurking shadows i witness an amazing growth of love and
pat in the pastures of time it'll feel empty about you by
our side but know that you change our lives for the better
please remember us whenever you are and remember the love
that you shared with us we will always share back x a
thousand thank you for inspiring me thank you for all the
wonderful things that you shared with us I'll always admire
and look up to you as an artist, as a community leader, and
a creator.
We will always stay as a loyal work knight through and
through.
Oh my god.
I'm not crying.
I'm holding it until the end.
Guys, oh gosh.
Oh.
That was so sweet.
Whoever wrote that one.
Oh.
oh but no like i said you guys make me so happy too you guys
do you guys do i think this is also why i do not collaborate
a lot too i feel like i'm one of the few like one of the
vtubers that don't really do a lot of collaboration streams
because all i really want to do is just hang out with my
chat and i feel like when i do collaboration streams i'm not
focusing too much on my chat i feel like oh my tension is
not really on my my chat now when i collaborate and honestly
i feel much happier just talking to my chat than like
collaborating with other streamers um so it's like you guys
just make my days so much and i always feel bad when i'm
like oh i'm ignoring chat i'm ignoring chat i just want to
hang out with them and say it's just ah thank you guys thank
you it really does mean a lot it really does all right let's
go to the next one um why are you stitch chat into single
watchers being collaborative it with it hey dokey when i
first found your stream through a raid it was when you had
taken off your skin shoot and shooting your true colors as a
as a tomato at first i found the concept of a tomato v2
refabulous so i stayed and laughed myself a while but i was
listening to your content humor most especially your laugh i
decided to stay and watch never had i ever thought about my
decision as a bad one and i doubt i ever will finding your
stream was damn well one of the best happened to me, but
only a week after watching your stream, you were announcing
your graduation.
It felt awful seeing that.
The new light that I just found was so fleeting.
I was in a pretty big rut and felt awful.
I don't know why I would still be here, weren't for you, but
I guess I can count as a blessing that I found you at all,
huh?
But I won't beg and plead you to say, I just want you to
wish that you had the best of luck in your future endeavors
and that you just remember us of course i'll remember you
guys i will never forget the bark noise chat you guys we
have so we have people hearing from all the way till 20 from
2017 like i'll never forget any of you guys do not worry do
not worry guys i always recognize people from my chat like
all every single one of you and i'm so happy that i changed
changing some of your lives for the better like I think like
um some of the streams I I I do my main touch is to make you
guys laugh because that's all I want to do make people laugh
I love making people laugh because it's like I know what
it's like to feel to feel down and I always want to make
someone laugh and have fun and I'm so happy that you guys
feel that feel the effort I bring out to all of you I'm
trying not to cry but I'm tearing up.
I'm trying so hard.
Doki, my beloved, you mean so much to me and I really mean
that with every fiber of my being.
Thank you for letting me be a part of your community and
inspiring me artistically and making me laugh when I wasn't
having the best day.
It means so much to me and I will treasure every moment I've
had in your streams.
Thank you and good luck with your future.
Felicity Machikai.
Machikai!
Thank you for that message.
Thank you so much.
I'm so happy that you enjoyed your time with the community.
I'm so happy a lot of you.
I'm really happy with the community I built to really, I
really am.
All the dumb stuff I came up with, the Bark Knights, the
Tomato Squad, like all the Doki Squad.
It was just like, like on the fly things and then we kept
these jokes up for so long for like these like these like
names for ourselves and these jokes for ourselves this inner
circle this inner community thing we had together our claps
our little dumb brain cells gimmicks I'm so happy that the
dokey squad anything for the dokey squad I'm just so happy
that Oh, we kept those.
Many of these jokes were like years, something that we came
up with like for years and like something that on the fly.
Thank you, everyone.
It really does mean so much.
We were able to keep this community through so long.
And please hydrate right after graduating.
How about that?
Good, good idea.
A little intermission there.
I'm not here for map and reading Fuck reading I'm not
reading Someone else's Wait guys I just learned how to read
I learned how to read for this particular stream It's a
miracle I know how to read guys My character arc Has finally
been complete Everyone We have finally complete I needed our
character arc.
I learned how to read.
Finally, I can re-chat.
I was going to learn to read.
I wish she forget after.
I wish she did it.
I did it.
The B movie taught me my ABCs.
We're all cousins now.
I really hope you have a happy and healthy life moving
forward and a fun doing what you do will never forget you.
I'll never forget you guys too.
Do not worry.
I'll never forget you guys.
You know, I'm so fast.
She finally passed first grade.
Hey, hey, doki, even though I didn't know you long, I really
enjoyed your streams the past month.
your stream in no matter the situation i love your laugh
it's seriously contagious too oh yeah and your thieving
skills second to none yep where are their points now gone a
beautiful heist i appreciate for not only uh appreciate for
i clearly my reading skills have not been that great i
already lost track where it was i appreciate for not only
what you have brought to the community but the impact you've
left on all of us i want to i want to work harder and bring
the kind positivity you brought to not uh to not to us to to
to oh brought on to us i was like to to to to to brought on
to us big or small best of luck in your future plans and
stay able to run you sneaky thief thank you from a forever
park night i'm sorry for for like I'm slowly losing my
reading skills there.
My reading skills slowly deteriorated there.
I was like, I was like, where did it go?
Thank you.
Thank you, everyone.
That was my message.
Thank you, J, for this message.
you again.
It really means a lot, guys.
They're all your messages.
So it didn't wait over and press on you.
It really means a lot that you guys take your time out to
write a personal message to me.
It really does.
Thank you, everyone.
We have been following you for a little while, but I'm so
glad I caught a few of your streams.
Can't help but smile and laugh every time.
A lot.
Thank you.
That was my goal.
I honestly, every time I started my stream, my goal was just
to make you guys laugh.
That's all.
And then I realized, man, And then if I realize I'm starting
to get angry because of apex I'll be like guys, we're gonna
have to stop because all I want to do is make you guys laugh
I don't want to be angry.
I want to be happy and funny Because I'm funny And if I'm
not funny, I make you guys laugh because my laugh forces you
to I can make dumb jokes funny if I laugh
Truly an amazing power truly amazing
brawley thank you for the sob at tier one thank you thank
you can we get some bark nights real quick for for brawley
for the tier one for one month thank you thank you thank you
i really do appreciate it guys thank you so much you can get
some bark nights real quick uh for brawley thank you thank
you guys thank you all so much i already told you to an apex
oh you oh yeah i remember that job are you happy at this
love and devotion fall even though oh thank you sunburn you
know we only met for a month and the first stream from you
was you announcing your graduating i had a massive time
hanging out around with you thank you for everything thank
you next sat thank you so much i'm glad you had a great time
in this month i'm so glad even though some of you some of
you might be discovering me today some of you might have
been discovered me like only like a month ago or like a few
weeks ago and i'm so happy like don't see it as like you're
sad that you weren't able to catch more of me just see as
you were lucky to see to see me before i go you know you're
lucky to be there but be in my journey before i go and i
feel like that's much more important than the the negative
part all right let's go to the next message how is everyone
going to know that you are the pony that you should know if
you don't stream anymore i swear even after you go if you
don't listen to the daily song every day then you have
failed me that is my dying wish to you all you guys better
be listening to that song every day or i will know i'll find
out i'll find out and I'll take your bark night badge away.
You know what, you see me and I'm so humble.
While we didn't know each other for so long, I enjoyed
spending my time watching streams and hanging out in
Overwatch.
I always be proud to be a bark night.
Oh, thank you, Steve.
Thank you.
I really do appreciate it.
Thank you guys.
No, no, no.
I'm not dying.
I never die, guys.
That was just a lie.
Because I'm a thief.
But it's okay, I'll tell you when I'm lying, okay?
But that way, I'm not dying.
people lying shake my head all right okay jake thank you for
hanging out with us i always appreciate jake i hope you have
a good night's rest or whatever you're doing the rest of
your day we have a good day thank you for coming by thank
you thank you all right let's do next one i only you know i
i know i've only been here for a few months, but we'll all
miss it off sometimes, especially with horror month in
October, but good times with the peepee man and your doors
in Minecraft, we love you and wish you good luck on the rest
of the journey, and now I can, I now will be free.
I'll never have to play a, I'll never have to play a horror
game again.
I'll never have to play a horror game again, guys.
There was, we will never have October month.
We'll never have Spooky month again!
I don't know if I was like, I'll never have to play spooky
games again.
No more spooky mansion.
Portal wasn't a horror game, more so of like, I just
devolved into a caveman at the end.
All I could do was just up, down, Up, down, where do I go?
Mike, thank you so much for the raid.
Thank you.
I hope you had a great stream playing Resident Evil Village.
Holy shit, did you play the...
What difficulty did you play?
I heard the difficulty in the, like, what was it, the
village difficulty or whatever?
I heard that one was really, really hard, and people just
rage quit at the Lady D part when she's like...
that part.
I don't want to spoil, but a lot of people rage quit the
Lady D part for the hardest difficulty.
I saw one guy when he was at a boss fight for Lady D.
He spent like six hours on the boss fight and then he gave
up and went to media mode.
And for like six plus hours he gave up and then like swapped
the media.
He replayed the game all the way.
He restarted.
started the entire game because he was like why not how you
play a big vampire i think we all know how we all feel about
miss lady d okay mrs dunky so i have so many of my tends to
call the channels i follow to a manageable size you're so
happy because of how always how happy you always seem to be
oh oh that's really sweet paul that really is sweet all
right thank you mate for the great times memories and
streams your laughs are amazing and always lift my spirits
you've built an amazing community and i'm glad to have been
part of it i wish you luck in your future endeavors though
this isn't a good guy hope to see you around every so often
bark nights forever bark nights forever bark nights forever
guys i hope you always remember the bark nights everyone
even in 50 years you will be like wow it's part of a called
the bark knights you're like was I Nicole I hope you the
clone of cousins bark knights forever I hope you'll always
remember the bark knights even in like 50 years or so April
I've been with you since the old day I don't think it this
thing is that long, but I know it's long yet to know you
mean a lot to me.
I'll miss you on your content.
Thank you for everything.
I won't forget a single moment.
Oh, I'm back.
Yes, I have a lot of you guys that would have been with me
since my Overwatch day since 2017.
Isn't that crazy?
And it's like, it's just crazy for me to think that you guys
put up with me for so long, for the many hiatuses I've done
for all of you too.
Like I would be like, I wouldn't even let you guys know.
I just disappear for months and be like, hey guys, and then
I'll be like, welcome back now.
But this is the final goodbye.
This will be the final goodbye.
So this is not a hiatus.
I just need to reiterate that this is, I know I've done a
lot of hiatuses in my time, but this is not, I have to, I
really have to reiterate that I'm not, this is not a hiatus
so that's why i'm like really surprised that so many of you
stayed with me for for so long even with all the shit i did
i pulled on you guys even with all this shit i pulled out
you guys being like i don't even warn anyone i'm just be
like i'm gone i'm just like sorry i'm missing for um four
months i'm sorry
i know i've only been here for a couple days but thank you
for making me laugh so hard your laughs are so contagious
and i love it when you say it is I wish I discovered you
sooner and I wish you all thank you, Sarah Thank you that
that really is not 50 years from now here son This is my old
body pillow.
It will laugh at you if you need it hug hug this anime girl
when you're sad boy
Boy are you sad hug the pillow But you go up to the little
boy part nights forever
Alright, let's...
Unfortunately...
We're cousins.
Oh my god.
See me?
Unfortunately, I discovered your channel.
The day you announced your graduation.
And during the last month, I wasn't able to join because of
college.
Or I would be tired and fall asleep.
But I've been able to watch some videos.
And it's been fun.
I just want to wish you good luck with the future.
And thank you for brightening up my day.
Thank you whoever sent that message.
Thank you guys.
I just thank you everyone.
It really does mean a lot.
Like I'm just happy that even for some people, for those who
are like the short times you guys watched me, that I still
left an impression on all of you.
And that really does mean a lot.
It really does.
I'm gonna hack my Doki Makura and play streams and laugh
from inside it.
man remember finding out like what are you and playing that
perspective just laughing about it's sad to see you go but
it was fun while it lasted oh my god what was it what was
that game the game I the one that where I broke the game and
and I what was that perspective game again I already forgot
but and then I end up apparently there was a I ended up like
brute forcing my way to solving the apple game super liminal
yes super yeah I forget every game I touch and then and then
you guys remember the apple part so you know I never know
remember how you like solve the apple part so apparently the
way I solved it was not a very conventional way of solving
it the tiny apple I was not supposed to solve it like that
so like for some reason the tiny apple just I just made so
many apples that the tiny that one tiny apple managed to the
drip towards me and and then i just literally made more it
was so tiny but i did it every puzzle i did for tiny out
every puzzle i did in superliminal was not a very
conventional way of solving it i broke that game so many
times Gumi!
Thank you for the raid, Gumi!
Thank you!
I hope you had a great stream.
I saw you were playing Pokemon Snap earlier, Gumi.
How was it?
But thank you again for the raid, guys.
Thank you again.
Thank you, Gumi.
I hope you had a great stream.
I'm just reading our marshmallows.
The final, final, final messages.
Oh, and good luck in your sub-a-thon tomorrow, Gumi.
Good luck.
Oh, yeah.
A great sub.
I heard like a maximum extension is like 72 hours or
something.
Like, it's like, Goombie, are you going to, are you going to
sleep?
Like, are you going to sleep?
Are you going to do a sleep stream, Goombie?
Thank you.
All right.
So, Hey, Berg, just last minute message to say, thanks for
all the laughs at first.
I found you on Twitter and just follow for art but I got
curious one time when I saw you streamed and we're playing
apex and honestly just kind of was in all watching you play
so different from what I've done myself you inspired me to
try more and I actually felt like I improved a lot from
there I just showed up because I was up way too late way too
often and it was always a blast to be around and hear that
laugh I know I stole my sword with the points but I honestly
glad I got to help out even if it wasn't that much.
You helped!
Is this Acer?
This has to be Acer.
You're the only one that stole the mod sword.
He's right now this is you because you're the only one that
stole the sword out of all of us.
But Acer, you helped out a lot.
You helped out especially the Minecraft server.
You helped out so much in Minecraft as well.
We all stole the sword at one point It was mods stealing
swords from each other.
I'm gonna miss hanging out with you and the rest of the bark
nights.
But I'm sure you're gonna keep doing amazing with what comes
next.
And it was really awesome seeing how much effort and thought
you kept putting into stream.
I think my favorite will always be seeing you cheer up
simply by going live.
Well, it's great to know we could help you out.
Okay, I'm gonna see you around.
I was dying for my sword.
whenever she'll smile I get it but you guys do not know um
we had a point where I had a thing where people could steal
mod from each other so like people who are non-mods can
steal swords from the mods and I thought it was like a fun
thing but I realized I was like okay this is gonna get
really bad because what if like we had this secret lurker
like a secret lurker that was like I'm gonna lurk in this
channel just to seal mine and then he bans everyone so I was
like maybe this isn't a good idea so I had to get rid of
that later I had to I was like you know what I realized
there was a there might be a secret lurker there that I
wanted to save all the points just to ban everyone refresh
them at our don't worry I'll refresh it guys I'll refresh it
when we get to the bottom how do you even do that it's just
like they just redeem the points um and they just slowly
they just slowly just bat everyone in chat not being the
great biggest heist of them all i gave up my server at least
feel strong man
all right let's see congrats on your graduation it's been a
wonderful to see your streams and hang out at the movie
nights we'll surely miss you and your infectious laugh And
continue to wish the best of you.
Don't be shy to still chat with us.
And we're all still here for you, Doki.
Congrats again.
And take care.
Thief of the Bark Knight's Heart.
Thank you, Dragon.
Thank you.
Guys, I really do miss all of you.
Thank you, everyone.
It really does mean a lot.
It really does mean a lot that you guys are taking your time
to write me these messages, guys.
It really does.
Because it takes me, like...
three plus days to reply to anyone it takes me that much you
don't understand typing a message to reply to someone in a
message takes me like three plus days you guys might notice
on Twitter how I reply to people like five plus days later
and I just reply to people in like in like a binge so like
you would see me reply to like 10 plus people all at once
and they'll range from replies from yesterday to replies
from messages from like 10 plus days ago and i'm like sorry
so it really means a lot um it really does mean a lot that
uh you're spot drop writing in the words b i am i truly am i
can't really say i'm so mad by can't go keep good luck keep
your head up have a good luck congratulations
congratulations we love you ah thank you yoy thank you you.
I really do appreciate you guys stopping by.
Really do.
Thank you for all for like hanging out this late.
I didn't think like the stream will go to this late already.
Thank you everyone.
But don't worry we're almost to the, we're very close to the
end.
We're very close to the end guys.
Do not worry.
What are three things you wish you knew about VTubing and
streaming before you started?
I'm debuting next month with no followers at all and I'm
just really excited.
just wanted to ask you have any cardinal wisdom to best best
bestow I was like best overwatch bestow I was like and also
in a few years I hope you can look back this chapter of your
life and smile I think it's really cool what you've done and
what you've built you've go far okay can't wait for the last
stream oh my gosh for advice lie okay this is what i'm going
to tell you guys you might be like what are you talking
about but i will tell you this i'll tell you this do the
opposite of everything i've done with my streaming career i
know like you're like what do you mean but i'm serious i'm
serious do the opposite of everything i've ever done with my
streaming career because like what i do is very
unconventional and that's why my growth has been very very
slow because like i don't i guess it's like it is sad that
i've got i did get rejected for a twitch partner like 40
times but it's like i did this to myself i did this to
myself so what i'm saying is that first off the biggest
issue with my with how i stream is that i don't i never
before i announced my graduation i've never like told anyone
what time i'll be streaming what day i'll be streaming and
when i do stream I do stream it's like 2 a.m.
It's like it's like 2 in the morning and usually if you want
to grow as a streamer do you not stream at 2 a.m.
Like there are a few degenerates out there like me that are
awake at that time and also the people on the other side of
the world but but it's not very good in good when it comes
to comes to growing as a
streamer and definitely don't definitely um definitely like
network more.
Me I just I was in the void.
I was I was in the void and locked in my discord I deleted
all the doors in my discord in my streaming room so I never
really like interact much with other especially in VTubing.
VTubing is all about networking and collaboration.
Not me though I like i look at v-tubing and i'm just like i
want to be pretty i want to have so many outfits and i just
want to talk to my chat but it's it's true though like
collaboration and networking is such so important in
v-tubing and i know that's awful so that definitely affected
my growth as a streamer Um, because I've been streaming on,
well, last year, I've been streaming consistently since
2020.
Um, since the beginning of 2020 was like when I started
consistently streaming.
And, uh, I, but I started streaming in 2017.
But it's just that I was so sporadic with my streams that,
um, that like I would go, like I said, I would go on to
this, uh, really, uh, I go on to this, uh, really like
sporadic hiatus and everything so that affected my growth
and all that stream consistently and yeah like those are my
advice stream consistently uh do not stream at two in the
morning collaborated networking i feel like at this day and
age is all about networking now um like when streamer reads
their messages i love reading messages i always make sure to
try and read all your messages guys i'm sorry if i ever
missed any because because like i I don't know, I was busy
reading the B-movie script.
So the B-movie script has made me very preoccupied, as you
guys know.
So I'm glad you guys enjoyed your time in my community and
with your cousins.
You get to my message in two to three days.
So thank you, everyone, for just being there with me.
It really does mean a lot.
It really does, guys.
So, yeah, just do the opposite of everything I've ever done.
That's my streaming career.
And then you too can become a Twitch partner.
And don't send them the B-movie script in your application.
Don't put the B-movie...
Clearly, I don't think they like the B-movie script very
much in my Twitch partner application, guys.
I don't think they did.
Don't do that, too.
that even as a certain meeting meeting it's been fun
watching your stream for two months and times went fast it's
kind of sad that you'll be graduating but it's your choice
and we can't stop you from doing what you want and finally
and finally good luck from your journey thank you tg3 thank
you everyone for the well wishes thank you all thank you all
if I wasn't graduating I would definitely write in my
application world cousins
But sadly I don't have a fifth attempt I don't have a fifth
attempt on that
How active are you going to be after your last stream?
You're just going to disappear in the YC And other streams?
Who knows?
It's really hard to stream when you're on the run, you know?
It's really hard to do anything When you're fucking running
from the cops, guys.
Have you ever tried Motel Internet?
Do the motels have internet guys?
I don't even know.
I'll find out later.
Gilgamesh, thank you for the 13 months at tier one.
Thank you!
Can we get some bark nights real quick for Gilgamesh for the
13 months at tier one.
Thank you, thank you.
I really do appreciate it, guys.
thank you so much thank you thank you everyone the final
bark nights the final bark nights hello dokey seeing as you
soon to be leaving forever i just want to thank you thank
you my sister passed away in november but it didn't truly
hit me until much more recently among other things your
streams and videos kept me happy and distracted me from
making any rash decisions to put it bluntly you saved my
life I decided to turn my life around on April 19th, and I
felt so much better since then.
My doubt I ever would have had the chance to do so if it
hadn't been you.
Your personality, charm, and infectious laugh has been the
highlight of the last seven months I spent watching you.
I can never thank you in love for truly reminding me that
life is indeed worth living.
I'll miss you forever and never stop loving you.
Hopefully that last part wasn't creepy.
But, but, oh my god.
Ah, whoever, whoever, whoever that sent that.
I'm so happy that I was able to, I was able to help you
there.
I'm very happy to be there for you during your dark times.
I'm just happy to, uh, I'm just happy.
I love you.
Have a good rest of your graduate.
Oh, thank you, Uncle Bear.
Thank you.
I'm just happy that I was able to help you there during your
rough time and that was able to cheer you up during that
time.
Like I said, I know I keep saying, but I just love making
people laugh.
And it's just, I'm just happy that I was able to do that.
I'm really happy to be able to do that for all of you.
And really, I just want you guys to feel better every bad
day.
And I think that's like people be like why are you laughing
so much and I'll be like what's wrong with like what you
don't like to be happy Man, I'm sorry Like you're like
what's wrong with laughing is laughing your allergy?
Oh Hope you die in game From me laughing too much Like I'm
just happy that I was able to Make you guys laugh and I'm I
it's really that's really all I wanted to do for you guys
that's really it like I start my stream being like don't
like me having to do overwatch someone did an uninstall
overwatch I see all right honestly hey Doki honestly I
didn't think I get emotional over this as I have been able
to be very active for now now because of IRL stuff but wow
I'm literally tearing up writing this out I'm so happy to
have had all these memories to you I still have the songs in
it because of your old playlist before Twitch DMCA.
I wish I could have edited for you more, and I'd known about
this.
I would hunt them 10 million thousand times.
This is an estimate.
I made more time to be able to make more memories with you.
I honestly will cherish this time of my life that we all got
to spend together.
And I hope the same is for you, Sparrow.
Ah, you guys don't know who Sparrow is.
He's also been in the community for a very long time.
He's been there with us for very, very long.
And since the Overwatch game, he's also known as edit a lot
of our videos too on YouTube.
So, I don't know, Sparrow's here right now.
Because he's been very busy lately with his school and work.
So, it's really sweet that he managed to send a message in
before the end.
And I'm going to miss him.
He has done so much for the community too.
He's also one of our mods.
He's also one of our mods too.
We'll miss your energy in that city.
laughter thank you whoever that was thank you i'm gonna miss
your stream so much that you're such a positive ball of
energy and i hope the feature is kind to you wherever it is
that you're going to pursue might include making tomatoes
extinct don't get the last tomato just wiped out tomato town
who's next been a follower ever since your overwatch days
and i'm glad i stayed for the journey Chuki, thank you
Chuki, thank you for everyone that stayed since my Overwatch
day.
It's really crazy because I went through so many different
phases in my streaming career.
Like I went through different things I want to do because I
didn't know what I wanted to do.
I went through like Splatoon Overwatch.
Remember when I used to be an artist?
I don't think we... When was the last time I drew for you
guys?
Because I was like, you know what, I'm just going to talk to
my chat.
I'm just going to talk to my stream because I was like...
Because I was like, I'm really just talking anyway.
I was merely just talking anyway, so I might as well just
ditch the whole art part.
That's what you mean.
Yeah, never true during the art tube.
That's true.
I just wanted to be in the art category.
Alright.
And after this, we refresh.
Hello there, traveler.
How are you doing?
Hope you're doing well.
i'm mad at saying goodbye my brain does not function
properly so i'm just gonna blurt out some words then where
to begin then i still remember i found out by your channel
during quarantine the pure chaotic energy was a breath of
fresh air it is true that i was not an active member of the
community neither was i there all the time but i believe uh
but believe me i loved all the stream i was able to see and
enjoyed every second of it loved your art love your pp but
most importantly loved you as a person it hurts to see you
go by respect your decision wherever you do next just know
that we will always support you until the next blue moon
rise and night is bright until the nice tikes goodbye here
you decide to go on high skin do more people just know that
we will be waiting here for you let god cross or pass once
again until then goodbye for the last time ah thank you for
whoever that wrote that like i said guys i will miss you
guys so much and i'm glad i made such an impact on all of
you uh don't forget me If you close your eyes, all will be
there.
Look at you.
Yeah, there will be more.
There will be more, guys.
Don't worry.
I'm just going to refresh this now.
But thank you, whoever wrote this.
That was such a sweet message.
Thank you, whoever it was.
I see that ring wrote some nice words, love.
All right, let's scroll back up.
my gosh 10 more oh you guys are so sweet everyone thank you
thank you it's so sweet eddie thank you for the five bitties
thank you thank you we prepare something special for your
final stream join me in the burst lesson discord with uh oh
okay okay i guess we're joining in the oh but i don't if
you're sharing a video to me i don't know if i can screen
can i share a video that's shared on the discord is it
possible to share that i don't know i've never tried that
before guys i've never tried that should be okay all right
all right i'll do that then um hey ducky i'm making this uh
while you read the messages that everyone gave you and hear
last it really makes me sad that i'll not hear it no more uh
because it's different when it's in the moment ah words just
saying it was fun watching and hearing your loud aggressive
and energetic voice out to see your twin the infinite doors
of opportunities on your way what are you talking about what
twin I'm an only child or I'm an only child what twin we
never had I never had a twin not since 2014 not since 2014
but thank you thank you there's extreme last minute I'm so
sorry about that.
Though I did not speak a lot in chat, I would like to thank
you for your time and effort you put into your stream.
I found you through a rain and I'm extremely happy that I
stayed.
I want to thank you for all the laughter you brought to us.
I always remember the first movie night I helped him to
watch Souls with the community, but nonetheless, I hope you
have a happy graduation and I wish you the best on your new
path of life.
I wish I learned about you sooner and talked more, but as
for now, I know you will be remembering and I hope you
remember of course I'll remember you guys chat of course oh
well I'm so happy I'm so happy even the movie nights even
like during movie nights you guys all had an amazing time
because every time in movie nights I try to like be as
involved as much as possible I even like paid to watch the
movies legally for all of you sometimes I would pay like 20
plus dollars to watch it legally because it'll be like like
soul.
I had to buy the ticket.
Or Raya.
But I am so happy that you guys all enjoyed.
All enjoyed the rip trolls.
Trolls I bought.
I even paid for trolls.
And that was the best decision of my life.
You wouldn't download a car.
That ad traumatized me.
But I'm glad y'all enjoyed, especially movie.
Movie night was so fun, too.
Well, movie night was so fun with all of you.
It was.
I'll miss your streams and your crazy antics on streams.
I made new friends with some of my fellow bark knights.
I've never been able to meet otherwise.
Especially these last few weeks with stream where we've been
able to hang out.
I'm happy to call you a friend if you're all right with
that.
I hope your future endeavors bring you good fortune,
especially since you were a thief.
Thank you for everything Doki, rain for days, your friend,
Ninja.
Oh, thank you, Ninja.
Thank you, everyone.
And Eddie, thank you for the other eight bits.
Thank you so much.
Doki and Scooby, too.
That's it.
Thank you so much, Ninja, for such a sweet message.
And thank you for all the stuff you've done.
You've only, even though you've only been here for a short
time, time, you really did leave an impact on all of us,
especially like the fun, the fun one me, the one me ones we
had, and the apex, and, and, and the big, great, big
donation that you made, um, for all of us, for like, for
food and for food banks of Canada, it really does, um, mean
a lot, and, like, the donation you did yesterday, too, like,
for two days ago like oh my gosh thank you ninja it really
it really was i'm so i'm so happy that you're all part of
this community guys thank you for making this such an
amazing community for me and i it's amazing community for
all of you hey doki it's your boy oh sorry just want to say
i'm going to miss you so very much seeing that message for
the final stream made me go in denial for a while until i
make peace and want you to succeed i'm happy i found you on
recommend it randomly at 2 a.m.
spending so much time even though I've missed most of stream
I have to watch the vlogs when I can when today finally came
no lie I cried home off and I got home from work I'll say
that you made my nights amazing when I came by the smile you
put on my face made my mouth heard from smiling trying not
to laugh hard at the day in the morning I'm gonna miss my
miss your streams gonna miss hearing the jokes the stories
chaotic energy and force your laughter who knew that you can
make me cry so hard for these three hours my up well I wish
you the best of luck and know that might as well feel cute
in your heart love you doki from one of the many work nights
oh thank you thank you thank you I'm sorry thank you for
such a sweet message yeah I wonder how many people I how
many people's parents or significant others or roommates
I've woken up because of my laugh Especially when I stream
at 3 in the morning.
I wonder how many of you guys accidentally woke up, like,
whoever you're living with because of me.
Yes, 3 in time.
Time to get in trouble.
Can we just saw that?
That way I can go away bleeding that a lot.
I switched my headphones up at 1 a.m.
I'm glad I have headphones on at all times.
It's a night terror for the north.
I think he woke in he woke in my my own's I Yeah, what's it
like to put on headphones?
I remember someone was like someone was like came to my chat
and was like I heard my boyfriend laughing And I knew it was
you from your stream and I was like whoops
I was like and she was like I was trying to sleep I don't
remember who it was.
I wish I remembered.
That was so funny.
I'm like, I'm so sorry for waking you up.
I'm so sorry.
She was like, I knew she was watching your stream because
you woke me up.
You woke my roommate in that massage stream.
I was like, the funniest shit.
Moving talking.
I never get to make my day riding, asking what was I because
you heard Doki screeching at Oregon.
have opened back headphones so I've been able to hear the
crazy laugh from another room when went up to do one thing
or another right now my donkey's laugh I got yelled at by my
parents one for laughing too hard from your streets yeah I
feel like everyone has got either like reprimand or yelled
at because of me I'm sorry but not really I mean I got
annoyed at you can't believe it's like me is annoyed at your
life they need to hear it the most ah yes what's it called
Stockholm I'm just gonna give whoever it is, Stockholm
Syndrome.
Hi again.
Warm said a second marshmallow message before the end.
I'm really super happy that I got to find your stream.
Although I've been coming as often as I would like, I'm
always so happy to feel so welcomed by you.
Thank you for being so amazingly kind and funny self.
My favorite moments was I say, Fuck you, oh dear.
I'm gonna stop laughing and just tell it how hilarious and
goofy you are.
I wish I didn't have to see you leave because I always
wanted wants to be able to see you having fun with the bark
knights i'm gonna miss hearing your laugh and witty humor
please take care of yourself and even though you're gonna
believe in this discord please feel free to come back and
hang out with all of us again you're seriously gonna miss
you so very much thief of bark knight hearts take care again
you'll destroy your stomach with your about that i it did
not work the next day was not very not very good day for me
i eat today was not a very good day for me when I woke up
let's just say that let's just let's just say that those
noodles were very it was very rough it was very rough do not
eat spicy noodles do not eat noodles that are way spicier
than you are used to that's for sure.
It just needs more training.
Don't do that.
Don't, don't, like, you remember when I said do the opposite
of everything I do?
Do the opposite of everything I do.
This is one of the many examples.
Or you should do the opposite of everything I do, chat.
Doki, you're amazing.
I found your, you, I found your Gumi showed me, Rufi.
You make me happy i've only known you since october and
because of for and because for me you were always early in
morning i missed them a lot but i sit here not crying i'm
enjoying the amazing thing about you i don't know you get
how amazing it is your your contain yours contagious just
hearing it makes me happy you just have said twitch a clip
of you laughing i know they could have said they couldn't
have said no i hope what happens in your life is amazing but
please don't catch you us they need to us call upon us the
bark nights will always rise for you yesterday today
tomorrow 50 years from now um or 200 2000 i know san lg only
means so much from a random person over on the internet but
please from as much as it's worth from a tomato it true
genuine and will never waver which i got i'm crying i'm sad
i would love if you could stay i know you can't i hope you
don't disappear off the internet emoji oh emoji
Thank you, Emochi.
I'm happy that you've been enjoying these streams.
And remember, you were here for the journey.
And you were here for me live.
And you could get to hear the laugh live, too.
Come on, people will be like, people will be like, people
will be like, oh, listen to this vibe of her laughter.
That ain't the same.
But you had it live.
laughter but I'm so happy you guys are you there you guys
are there for me for this journey I may have only known you
for a few days doki but I also love your infectious charm
and your laughs just send me every time I'm sad that my
first time doki stream is the last one but I'm happy I came
you're awesome bark nights forever bark nights forever um I
just want to make sure that you're okay okay it's not health
reasons the it's just the do you want me to be in jail for
robbing a bank guys i'm pretty sure bank people are like you
can't go i mean they are for the first time but when you rob
them a second time they're like no no no no no we're gonna
fucking put you in jail and i I'd rather be in Motel 6 than
in jail, because then I could order Uber Eats.
Well, then my bunnies can order Uber Eats.
I said most of my thoughts in another document, but I
couldn't pass up one more opportunity to say how much you
mean to me and how happy I am for you.
I'm going to miss all this so much.
Thanks again for modding me at another mod's expense at one
time.
part of everything.
I love you so much.
I'll always support you and always be your number one sim
and number one mod.
That was CV.
Oh my gosh.
CV.
Thank you.
CV was also one of the original mods and one of the original
mods and one of the, one of my first viewers when I streamed
Overwatch.
And it's crazy.
He's been here for a long time.
He's been in this journey for a long time.
And it's crazy that he's been subbed to me for so long Like
a tier 3 CB.
And it really does mean a lot that you've been with us for
such a long journey and for for for so many years.
For so many years.
And I always say I always say that I I could never I can
never believe that a lot of especially the people from
months ago like years ago that's been with me to this day.
To this day, I recognize so many of you guys who are over
the years of street new and old.
It's just crazy to think about every time.
Hello, hello, resident Mon and VR chat addict here.
As you probably have already seen, Doki Maple Bird, I hereby
thank you for all the amazing months of entertainment.
I'm so glad I was able to share the joy and laughter how
contagious it is for every stream.
Coming from the hairbringers self-appointed leader of the
Doki squad and number one simp fan i assure you the money i
spent on the gifted subs merch charity and whatnot was never
a waste as all of it pays for the last nine months of
horrors streaming horror streams puzzle games the shooting
macface apex streams and just the chat streams what emo are
in the background it has been some of the greatest content
to ever grace my eyes and bring out laughter and never
thought was possible and everything else you have also
helped me by my be my true self and be who i am paid like a
thief to my butthart you heard now justin's under chain
though you're the dokey the herby pony should know oh thank
you ruby thank you and arlo and ruby thank you for the five
gift of subs each of the community can we get some more bark
nights real quick for arlo and ruby for for arlo and ruby
thank you so much for the 10 gift of subs and all you
everyone oh gosh ruby thank you so much ruby for all your
especially when you like sometimes you might be the only mod
in chat too during my really fucked up hours and it really
means a lot yamashi thank you for the five gifted too all
right more park nights but as i was saying thank you guys
for our park nights again in chat i was saying like thank
you for just like sticking around in the chat and just um
helping out with the modding moderating and stuff when
everyone's asleep It really does mean a lot.
While you're, like, busy at work.
It does mean a lot, Ruby.
Because I know, like, some of my hours are really fucked up.
So, thank you again.
Thank you for all your time and all your energy spent on the
stream and for how generous you all are.
Thank you, guys.
Thank you.
I really do appreciate it.
Okay, I'm going to refresh one more time.
And then, if that's it.
I will oh there's one more I'm so happy I met you in one of
your art streams 2020 was harsh year for all of us and
probably the worst year for me but after joining your stream
for the first time you really made my days a lot better I'm
going to miss that contagious laugh your jokes and just you
in general you've been such a joy and every time I come in
even if I'm lurking I always feel comfort in being your
streams thank you for letting me be a bark knight and
sharing so many fun
Thank you, thank you, Embers.
It really does.
Like I said, I know I keep saying this a lot, but I'm just
happy that I was able to make your days better, especially
during the quarantine months.
Like, it's rough when you're not able to go outside
sometimes.
So I'm happy that I was able to give you, like, smiles and
entertainments, make you forget about the bad things out
there in the world.
And it just means a lot.
It really does.
Thank you again.
Thank you, everyone.
It really does.
And Ransom, thank you for the 300 bits and for...
for the tier one community sub gift and Osala for the gift
two, thank you everyone.
More bark nights in chat, more bark nights in chat guys.
Thank you, thank you everyone for all the gifts guys.
It really does mean a lot, thank you.
It really does, thank you everyone.
You guys made me tear up so many times, thank you.
Thank you guys, thank you all, thank you.
All right, folks, before, before, the last thing um we have
a little apparently a little special thing from roar so let
me join the discord real quick and see if i can do the
thingy so just uh
see if i can set it up properly for you all i don't know how
to do it properly so i'm trying to figure this out guys i'm
dumb i don't know if you guys remember that part about me
all right yes i'll my twitter handle will be the same it
will be the same guys do not worry uh let me see if i can do
this let's see i don't think i can i what's it called what's
next oh yeah wait wait okay i need to try to figure out
which guys i'm trying to figure this out guys there we go
we're in all right roy let's do it let's Go, we're in.
Oh,
wait, wait, wait, wait.
Before, wait, wait, wait.
Don't do it.
Don't I just realized.
I fucked up.
We are not in.
We are.
I fucked up.
Look how tiny this box is.
Okay, this is pretty scuff, but I'm figuring out this out as
we go along, guys.
As we go along.
Is this it?
We're in.
Ninja!
The 45!
Thank you, Ninja!
Can we get some, before we play this video, can we get some
Barth Knights real quick?
To Ninja.
Thank you, thank you.
I really do appreciate it.
Thank you, Ninja.
We're the 45.
Give the songs.
Thank you.
is so much.
Oh my gosh, it is lagging roar.
You might have a little problem.
Bro, I just see your mouth.
It's a very long video just so you know.
How long is it?
Oh, wait.
Oh, you mean the video itself?
I don't know how to fix it.
I don't know.
Oh, shit.
Okay.
Wait, is it fixed?
All right.
Over an hour.
Or I can't stream this for an hour.
I'm sorry.
Or is there a way to stream like a quickie of it?
I will watch it after I can't I can't do an hour.
I'm sorry.
I will or is there a way to do like a little oh that's where
I should no it's just that um I have like something else
planned for you guys and I can't I don't want to I don't
want to like um delay this for wait too long but I can
upload the video to YouTube I can upload the video itself to
YouTube too can we get like one more daily song at the end
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah I'll upload a video on and we I'll
do a premiere I'll do a premiere and then we can all watch
it together at the end of the stream how about that I'll do
premiere tomorrow we'll do it to premiere of Roar's video on
YouTube tomorrow and we can all watch it uh on stream yeah
that'll be so much more fun I think that'll be much more fun
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah let's do that let's
do that Roy is that okay with you Roy so it will all be
we'll all be there too together watching it live all all of
us together yeah no no tomorrow on a youtube premiere it'll
be on my youtube channel as a premiere um is that okay roy
or would you prefer we watch it now roy would you prefer it
today well you pick because you you did this video and it'll
be uh you can add us more and more stuff all right upload to
for everyone to see yeah be everyone can see it too it won't
just be me yeah
so follow uh oh my god roi go to roi i'm so sorry roi oh my
god i hope you're okay roi are you okay go to see okay i
said don't worry don't worry we're almost at the stretch and
then you can pass out and then we will have a youtube
premiere we'll have a YouTube premiere where we all can all
watch it together as a as this as the bark night some the
final thing um the final thing as bark nights together final
thing more we want to sneak peek oh let's just sneak peek
yeah yeah yeah sneak peek okay okay let me we'll do a sneak
peek and then the rest will be a YouTube premiere and then
we'll have the rest as a YouTube premiere that's good that's
a good idea yeah okay let me fix this real quick I need fix
this.
I just need to reset and then okay.
Alright, play it.
We'll get a sneak peek and then...
You did a trailer?
Oh, just show the beginning.
We'll do a sneak teaser, 5 minute teaser.
A 5 to 10 minute.
And then...
And then, um, we'll all watch the rest tomorrow on a YouTube
premiere.
Alright, let's go.
Thank you, Roar.
Thank you for spending so much time for all of us.
It really does.
It's a whole thing.
Thank you.
We really do appreciate it, Roar.
Thank you for spending that much time for all of us.
It really does mean a lot.
Whoa.
A documentary.
Oh.
April 16, 2021.
I like picking the one song that I wanted to sing for you
guys.
It was very hard because I wanted to be a good song.
That was what I wanted to share with you guys for the
announcements.
So it was very hard picking this song.
And I feel like I'm not going to do very well on this song
because there's like this very high note, one for a specific
line.
And I might just sing it lower.
That's me.
Who's the real one?
hey we'll have our last conversation and drink our last cup
of coffee someday we might be 80 best win and think about
the different things we used to say all the memories of you
will just become a ghost of a smile got in the wind someday
the last day.
Oh, this is the last day.
I'll be graduating on May 14th.
It must be a surprise for all of you.
We're not crying.
I honestly had no idea how I was going to transition.
Today we celebrate.
It's final time.
It was so bad.
Relax, enjoy.
Let's go out with your name, shall we?
Oh.
It was but a simple raid.
It was a more innocent life.
Just got into watching these superheroes for her life and
was perusing the Twitch scene.
Then, some raid or else watch invaded you.
First I was in denial.
Her laugh was revealed.
Surely, that must be her whole schtick.
But after a few moments, the topic of Funko Pops arose.
My stone-cold heart hadn't laughed so hard and so long.
I had forgotten what it felt like, but I was still innocent.
I didn't realize this was just the beginning.
The more I watched, the more I became aware of the fact that
I was indeed witnessing peak content.
Peak content!
that we're not like to send just chatting and of course fun
apex times with acid and webbing and now we're so skilled at
the shooty game made for some great moments and hilarious
times uh yes
okay we know this is everyone's mom this is everyone's mom
What the fuck was it I supposed to do?
You rescued me.
I was like, okay, I'll just take your portal.
Oh, no.
Wait, it's in the middle of the fucking open.
No, you already died two times before that.
It's always that I says fault.
It's never my fault.
Not the second time.
I'm sure.
It's never the streamer's fault.
I'm streaming.
Kiss, kiss, kiss.
It was like, oopsie.
All right, all right.
I'm waiting for you guys to...
You know like what I said acid and what big arguing just
sound like an old married couple When they argue it's a
cousin's phone Big old grin on my face I started to notice
the floor a chink in the content armor a Chink in the
content armor you're a terrible freak
Seems I know I know you give more than you grow The force of
you worshiping money over anything else.
How dare you!
Back into the community.
The force of you...
No!
I've been exposed!
It's not only just Uber Eats.
I feel attacked.
Oh, look at the mouse traveling.
of each game i hope that's in some form give me a second oh
no oh no more nights for kurama kurama roy thank you roy
though it's really is that this we want to end this with a
sneak peek we might we might the might as might be the sneak
peek that was a really good teaser though roy that was This
is so good!
Oh, let's go, let's keep going.
Wait, are we going to keep going?
First knee.
This is so good.
Because a world without less would be by far your worst
crime.
Oh.
Four to five months of watching you.
My life has been so much more than it would have been.
And I value the little time I've spent.
Except in Trilly.
As most people, I am of course sad.
couldn't last for longer but always know that despite what
you decide to do in life you will always have love oh yeah
an accurate message and then the rest will be on the vid
tomorrow yeah oh thank you guys a lot all right i think
that's a good i will always remember why i said i guess that
would be a good preview for everyone just i will tell i will
let you notify because the discord will be up for for i will
still i'll be i'll i'll be there for tomorrow's so I will
get a notification I'll add every no actually hmm let me
think of it okay I will upload the video I'll do a premiere
of it and just join the YouTube I'll just join the join the
just subscribe to the YouTube channel and I'll make a little
premiere for the video for tomorrow and then word that was
beautiful that was really beautiful thank you for all your
time even though with a sneak peek I can tell how much work
Rory you should put your own message there before you give
me the raw video Roy put your own message there you really
deserve it I really look in the deep of my heart thank you
for for making that video Roy it really is beautiful like
that little sneak peek I showed you showed us was truly
beautiful and I'm gonna upload a I'm gonna make a little I'm
gonna do make a little schedule for a premiere of it
tomorrow and then the person I appoint for the discord owner
uh will make a notification for all you of what time it'll
be so ed thank you for giving 29 subs to the community thank
you can we get some bright nights real quick for ed thank
you thank you thank you everyone again like i said it really
does mean a lot all the love and support you've shown me and
we're finally on the final stretch we're finally at the
final stretch of the stream and i'm gonna do a little be
right back for a bit to set up for the final thing that i
want
uh and then and then we'll see from here thank you again
everyone okay some park nights for ed for the 25 gift itself
thank you again all right guys i'm gonna be right back and
um and then yeah i'll be back
oh my gosh we're finally here the last stretch i just want
to i guess my final message is to all of you like I honestly
I like I said I never thought I would build a community like
this ever I never thought that so many of you I didn't even
think that so many of you would come to the final stream it
really I'll be like oh I hope I hope I have at least 100 100
of you guys show up for the final stream because I want you
guys all to be here to like watch this live and like and
just be here and just experience the last stream the last
moments we have together and and it really means a lot thank
you all of you guys for for coming show for sticking around
and and just hanging out with me and whoa whoa whoa what's
that what's going on what oh no oh no Oh They're here Doki
maple You're months up We are here to take you in Oh they're
here Not go on the run and evade capture I repeat Do not go
on the run No shit Oh we made it too long We made it too
long Okay guys we Okay we might have We might have They
don't ever catch me Okay we might have We might have fucking
Drag the stream on too long Okay guys I need a I need okay I
need to Give me a sec guys I need a I need a change real
quick Everyone I need a I need to take off my skin suit.
They can't catch me if I'm a tomato.
They can't catch me.
I'm a tomato, everyone.
Do not worry.
I'm taking off the skin suit.
There you go.
It's okay.
We're fine.
We're tomato.
They don't know who I am.
You don't know where it went.
Oh, gosh.
Okay, okay, okay.
Chat, remember when I said I had to take a day off to teach
the bunnies how to drive?
Yeah, this was a lesson I learned.
Bow bow.
Me, me.
Get the car running.
we're going on the run now i can't believe i had to dispose
of that skin suit i'm to make a new identity maybe maybe a
new hairstyle what clip on here should i choose next guys
you think i can pull a non-blonde look no no but i can't let
the cops find me that easily though so i gotta dig around my
tree a passport which was something new guys just so much
work to do fine you think you see me on the streets no
snitching all right we're in the this together now park
nights forever but before my before i go my park nights
here's your little secret i robbed that bank again for a
reason this special gift for all you after i go wasn't cheap
but it was worth it now here's one last kiss for all you
here's one last one last what wait why what
until we meet again
My dear bark knights.